[Music]
come on
let's go
[Music]
get out pick it up
come on
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
jesus there's more oh my god this is
insane
[Applause]
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about
magic time
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back for the final weekend of
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
alongside me the everyone's favorite
international master
levy rosman danny we mesh
i just looked over i didn't know what
shirt you were wearing we're not i like
i don't have a green pawn though
i need is that new merch i'm gonna get
you one of these so this was our meetup
shirt from this year because we didn't
actually get to have a meetup due to
covid oh wait am i allowed to say that
word oh man we are start off on the
wrong foot anyway
uh what we've got is a couple of
isolated pawns because everyone has felt
isolated but we put on chessboard it's
very
symbolic so i'm gonna get you a shirt
i've actually got like five extra
upstairs in the office
i'm gonna get your get your addi and
ship you one real quick so
anyway how you doing man are you pumped
to be here this is how many how many
jokes can we make today that you don't
need a gm for a chess show
uh a lot you know uh i i'll say this
danny
i'm gonna say like i people people get
hype when whenever i'm doing commentary
but i always defer
to you and i'm always kind of like
everything that i've ever done
commentary wise
has been molded by danny wrench so it's
crazy to be
alongside you because now i i
you're the you're like the color
commentator like i gotta i you know i
feel like i'm sort of with like the
mentor the
the idol for this job it's it's weird
because um
that means the world to me i appreciate
that you're that you're the i'm gonna
drive today you're gonna be the chess
expert but
jokes aside we know uh we we love
working with all our hosts but levy and
i don't get to host that often so we're
gonna have a blast today
let's dive in remind everybody of the
show man we got a format that is
started in groups the players get to
play round robins but it's all about
coming into the bracket stage where both
the consolation and championship
brackets will get us down to a winner
single elimination is what it is the
same time control you know and love ten
minutes plus five second increment
and then the tiebreakers and we did have
an epic tiebreaker yesterday that
that had the uh the chess world and the
streaming world of buzzing
between ludwig and sardosh it's five
minutes per side
um and the finals of course of the of
both the consolation and the
championship brackets will take place
tomorrow february 28th levy big prizes
right we doubled the prizes this time
100 100 000. we're only taking some of
that out of what we're paying you to do
commentary you're good with that
i i am good with that i was not
expecting it to
to take that direction uh but uh no so
these are uh
dude these are amazing prizes you know
um for for anybody
that that tunes in at the beginning of
the show and not in the uh the first or
the or the second hour it's kind of
insane because twenty thousand dollars
for first place dude that's
like grand masters don't get that for
winning the world open which was
historically the biggest open
you know prize fun tournament in the
united states so it's awesome
it's true and nelly yeah there's a lot
of a lot of eyeballs on this event too
and while some of the players in this
event
maybe wouldn't have ever thought of it
that way but they are some of the most
watched chess players of all time and
some of the most handsomely rewarded
chess players of all time and it's a lot
of fun
speaking of handsome rewards the
community came in clutch yesterday levy
i would love to get to another another
epic goal today with the two of us
driving the show it's it's every dime
counts everyone it does go to charity
and every dime is matched by chess.com
so can we can we at least get over 30
today maybe get close to that 35 000
marker
let's find out let's find out together
all right and before we dive in
one more moment to uh thank our first
sponsor of the day gaia ki
of course they are our official
regenerative
yerba mate and they're celebrating 25
years make sure you spam
the gaia key emote in the chat for your
chance to win a case
um we do have a lot in the office levy
did you get your your case at gaia key
yet
but yeah i did i've been i've been
enjoying sipping on that orange essence
i think it's called so yeah
i've got i've got i've got classic gold
in front of me here and i've also got a
cue coming in from my producer that it's
time for us to take our first break the
players aren't quite set yet so we're
going to take a very quick break
don't go anywhere when we return more
specific previewing and the actual games
going down
between rayne wilson and benji fishy
pogchamps 3 presented by grip six
reach deep into yerba mate culture and
you'll discover
people have long gathered to imbibe mate
to awaken the mind
perform extraordinary feats and exchange
confidences brewed from the naturally
caffeinated and nourishing leaves of the
species of holly native to the south
american atlantic rainforest
come to life with guayaqui's wide
assortment of yerba mate offerings
all with powers to unite and energize
subscribe to one channel free
i'm bj minton the founder of grip six
when i was 14 my very first job was a
janitor at an elementary school
and i saved up my money and one of the
first things i bought was a wooden
chessboard
from the mall i love chess chess is
challenging chess is thinking ahead it's
planning it's problem
solving it's very similar in
manufacturing because in manufacturing
it's nothing but problems but problems
are what stimulate your brain
problems are the things that actually
push you into creating new things new
technology better products things like
that
at grip6 we make belts wallets and socks
we guarantee them for life
and just like chest they'll be around
forever
i love that first of all just want to
say from the
founder and out of everything at one
point over there at grip6 the guy
started himself of course
and uh everything about grip six is an
extension of him and they are awesome
i'm fiddling with my chest wallet in
front of me right now but
i gotta remind all of you that you can
go get a chess themed wallet they are a
special back order they sold out
but if you go to go.just.comgrip6
use the code pogchamps20 you not only
can get 20
off but you can sign yourself up for a
order they are going to make a limited
quantity to catch up
uh with the with the high demand that
they received for the wallets of course
you can also get
belts wool socks which again i'm wearing
some right now i actually have that
exact pair that you see on that image
it's kind of the neon green they feel
super comfy
so um i've got anyway
yeah i love you go ahead nice i got the
i got the low-cut red ones
i'm a little bit ashamed to admit you
know in these quarantine times how how
long you can leave socks on your feet
and not change them
they were very comfortable you know they
were so comfortable with that hey
don't ever be ashamed to admit that i
mean i you know it's uh
business up top party down low that is
the life of a streamer
all right here we go let's preview these
matches we've got rain wilson versus
benji fishy
uh this is um this is the the last
matchup that will decide who plays
sardoche in the championship and so
regardless of the fact that i think
sardosh is the favorite
no matter who he faces i this is a coin
flip today right obviously
those who who've been paying attention
know that i've been working with rain we
know benji's been working super hard
with
young love big hammer norwegian
grandmaster but i you know i i told
reign i think i think uh him
and benji are two of the best players uh
left and i have no idea what's gonna
happen
yeah totally and basically the way it
seems right now
is that uh sadosh benji
and and and rain are obviously uh the
three strongest but to be honest like it
it really felt like a comeback story by
by ludwig yesterday
uh he he played he played unbelievable i
was hype i've never
been as hyped as i was yesterday
watching that match it was like the
whole
you know uh pre-show hype with the music
and then the storytelling love's got a
very
you know compelling way to keep your
attention so that was sick i wish he had
held it together a little bit more under
the you know under the pressure of the
blitz game but
um how was your did you do any prep with
uh with rain for for benji
uh we did we did i'm not gonna get into
it yet because obviously we'll see what
happens on the board but we um
you know obviously i'm a big believer in
the prep being
focused on focus on what you do best
don't try to change things at the last
minute because we know how often that
can actually backfire
i think unless your opponent has
revealed like some
obvious weakness right then then really
it's just about
improving your openings improving your
approach to things so that you're in the
best space possible
speaking of being the best space
possible i think the games are starting
in fact looks like they have and we're
off to see the wizard
with a french and we did look at this
full disclosure because benji
for the record has pretty much only
played a french
in in his uh in his chess career and so
brain and i spent some time just looking
at the basics of the advanced variation
no trickery and you're gonna see that on
the board
yeah advance is uh it's a hot subject of
debate
because i remember way back when i told
hikaro i don't think that this is like
the best
way for white to try to you know get a
french player out of their comfort zone
but but to be honest if you prepare like
the miller berry with bishop to d3 which
is very tricky
right uh i don't know okay so you you is
this is this still uh
man i guess i'm just gonna have to talk
about it because it's happening i did
not expect this to happen necessarily
because
benji has also played some different
stuff um but this is the mainland french
and i well i agree with you i initially
tried to get rain to play my own knight
to c3
which is move three knight to c3 for
those wondering
but ultimately he felt really
comfortable with the structure and he
feels like that's the one thing that he
feels
kind of confident about is getting that
structure and so um
you know we worked through the basic of
the advanced ideas we talked about
playing a3 so that you could get b4
and we see that benji has actually not
stopped that so we'll see if rain plays
b4
which is what we looked at and and i
hope that he follows through with kind
of the idea
you know i i'm not going to see this is
no don your profit here when i coach my
students i'm not looking
for a check mate and six moves all due
respect to the profit right i'm just
like hey man
this is what you're doing in this
structure this is where your pieces
belong you're a good player this is the
middle game ideas you'll get
and go for it the craziest thing about
benji is that he's had his chess.com
account since 2018.
in january of this year january 10th
his rapid rating was 817 he has gained
545 points he is currently at his peak
which he hit yesterday so this kid
and that's insane danny like 100 percent
and and he's been growing i mean
hammer's been tweeting about it they've
been playing practice games
right training games um so he is he is
all in
and when we first invited benji because
of the fortnight conflict he had
he was he was that he really wanted him
but he wasn't sure he could get it not
only has he played in pogchamps but he's
maybe going to knock on the door to
getting in the final against sardoche so
we are officially in original territory
in terms of our prep just so the cat is
out of the bag danny working with rayne
wilson
i i talked to him about playing b4
if given the opportunity and that that
would be the best way to relieve the
pressure on the queen side
he's kind of mixed up the line a little
bit here with this bishop d3
but obviously it's still okay white is
still in a in a good space but the
reason i taught him b4 levy
is because now you can't play bishop e3
because queen takes b2 so
he's kind of forced to part ways with
the light square bishop which is really
not ideal
to be fair though benji also took on d4
early which is also not ideal because
it's giving rain this move knight to c3
yeah exactly that's actually the like
the the the deep meta of
of all of this opening is that white
waits to move the b1 knight wants to put
it on c3 i'm drawing arrows on my own
board because i'm so used to it
but uh yeah and actually rain does rain
know this idea from your training or
does he just
realize that snapping that knight is
just nice because now you're gonna play
knight c3 and hit d5 i think he knows he
messed up because
in theory he kind of didn't have a
choice i mean okay you can play the
gambit lines but the move order he
played
there's no way to defend the d-pawn
other than taking here
right that yeah that's fair right
because bishop e3 okay now he goes b4 so
i guess the the real issue is that
white trades the light squared bishop
and has
six pawns out of seven on the wrong
color square you've got a dark squared
bishop left but all your pawns are on
dark squares
so still computer is like trying to say
white has some advantage and that
basically rests in the fact that black
has those two bishops but the position
is very closed
so yeah yeah and
one of the things probably benji should
have done instead of castles to take
advantage of the way rain played it is
to play
try to play move like a5 in some of
these positions where your
your goal is to pry open and kind of
target the queen side especially with
white's inability to play b5
you can sometimes do with a bishop on d3
so so i think um
the question will be interesting as to
whether benji understands this a5 idea
have him and hammer talked about that
that's a key point in undermining the
front structure
did they not get around to that because
they didn't necessarily expect a3
i think that's going to be a key thing
in this position and we see he kind of
doesn't and he's actually blundered the
d5 pawn so
this is not working out well for benji
no it's not
and uh okay i mean the truth is that
after knight takes d5
e7 is still protected so computer is
giving like plus four
something completely ridiculous because
it's got a very kind of methodical way
now to pick apart everything and win but
rain's got to see through everything
like he's gotta realize that taking on
e7 is good and then he's gotta realize
like the next step it's not just winning
a pawn
it's that black's position is gonna
crumble right but
i i think he kind of got lucky the bench
he just didn't play bishop e6 there
right um but but okay he's gotten the d5
pawn and now he should be in control
uh speaking of uh speaking of in control
the community continuing to
guide us they're steering us toward this
thirty thousand maybe thirty five
thousand peter kkg
ij just donated 100 bucks and we've had
some other smaller donations
too so thank you so much hoping to reach
our goals yet again for uh the second
day in a row
all right man i and i know
i don't know how you feel i know that
anna gets super nervous with her
students i know that you know just
different coaches and different
personalities
when i'm here i legit feel zero pressure
like maybe that's because i'm detached
maybe it's because i have four kids so i
don't really care what rayne does
you know i don't know you know he he he
doesn't listen to me half the time in
the lessons anyway
so um you know i mean i'm just gonna be
honest and
if he's gonna trash me no i'm kidding he
he's great but i i
levy jokes aside do you feel pressure
when your students are playing that they
do what you did or are you kind of
emotionally unattached
it's it's been a while right so before i
was well even when i was streaming i i
ran a scholastic chess program
uh for those that don't know and i think
i felt
that pressure for a kid that was like a
good kid
like a kid that you know works hard like
i want them to do well
not like brady wilson not a good kid
well yeah like i had those
students that like wouldn't pay
attention bless him so like you know i
had a kid the last round of states like
we were in the running
for sure i was nervous in those moments
for sure yeah no no no
no no no so there's a plot twist so this
kid is like he's like not a very nice
kid like you know very you know pompous
kid whatever
comes back made it in eight moves
and i remember looking at him and being
like
well shouldn't they talk [ __ ]
like you know alex in that moment i was
like how do i counterbalance
my desire to be a good one please clip
that that is the best chess coach advice
to your kid losing a big game
flip that and ship that for levy rosman
please on twitter okay
rookie will play by rain great move and
obviously regardless of our discussion
on the opening prep
brain didn't quite get what i work with
him on but clearly i think benji
struggled with the advanced line anyway
uh not knowing kind of the a5 idea so in
the end
you know let you know benji's big
mistake of taking too early on d4 is a
good lesson for french players because
that's really what leads
to the advantage ring got here with
knight c3 and the d5 plunge so
this has got you know benji's got to
work his way out of this i'm with levy
it's not as clear of a win as the eval
bar would make you think
um after that move it might be although
after that move
if you take c7 you've got d5 we got
forking problems on the d file we also
have taking f6
oh this is gonna get spicy
yeah this is the oh okay see the problem
well you know that's a great move
uh but benji's gotta find bishop d5 like
it's a great move unless you play bishop
d5
you gotta plug the square right yeah
good point
because this is not yeah go ahead sorry
i was gonna say bishop yeah
bishop f7 e6 d5 i mean black resigns
black forget black stops playing the
french defense after two f7
so i did tell i did tell rain that i
said my main goal is for you to get
hammer
to feel like he needs to switch his
students openings like that's the main
goal and he's like who's hammer
like don't worry about it yeah that i
always wonder you know in these events
like
how many of these creators know each
other like
not even by name you know just by my
content all this stuff because they're
they're all over they're all working
you know maybe even hundreds of hours in
a seven day week
i'm just curious like you know do people
listen to logic's music
but put that you know and then like you
know do they watch mr b's videos there's
so many different people across so many
different
uh kind of categories but you know back
to the chess uh this is uh looking like
your guy is going to win the game
because falling apart um well
it is one of the funny things about
having having rain in the event because
he's
i mean the dude's dwight schrute right i
mean yeah
he's he's maybe maybe the name reign
wilson isn't trending in the same way
that you know mr beast or pokeman is but
we know the office is still the most
watched show
netflix said so and um if you if you
google how can i watch the office you
would be following a google trend
because most people freaked out
when that content is officially on
peacock by the way i'm subscribing to
peacock
pretty much for the office i don't i
don't know about that that peacock is an
animal with a
fancy tail the new mbc streaming service
everyone's goal these days is to shut
down content lock it down so that we all
have
75 subscriptions we have to make are you
allowed to promote
another streaming way on a streaming
website yeah
not oh man we'll cut it out of the
youtube vodka oh
you know i'll add it to the list of
streaming platforms i shouldn't be
mentioning
a lot mixer
okay wait if i go to google and and i
type in peacock am i gonna do it
am i oh okay that's just an animal
it's just okay um anyway
rain rain is definitely cleaning up here
so tough lesson for benji i think that
um
[Music]
rain again didn't get what we looked at
but the
the goal i took as a coach ate off
because i was like look man
always what happens here is most the
time you look at these specific x's and
o's he plays a move order
one of you forgets it focus on the
forest through the trees what are you
doing here and that's really
legit is my mindset and i think it's
partly because you just have had i've
had so many experiences where
when you try to go the other way and
buckle down and say this is the exact
trap
the amount of times you get what
happened between charlie and xqc
levy is like one in a million right it
just
never works out that way so you should
focus on your bigger chess goals
rather than trying to trap people all
right i'll get off my soapbox about
coaching all right here we go
yeah and that was that you know that was
a that was a point of like contention
right
uh because on the one hand you want your
you want your student to win
speaking of which like that story of the
kid losing in eight moves that was an
opening trap you know and like
sometimes you lose in an online
three-minute game sometimes he was in
the last round of the state championship
like
right it happens to everybody yeah
yeah exactly i've been caught i remember
i was there was there was a day i was
streaming i was like on a roll
and then a guy gave me a piece in the
open i'm like what is this i got mated a
few moves later and and it was a trap i
got trapped like
i thought i knew the traps all the traps
i got trapped
queen sack from mate like the most nasty
trap i've ever seen so
you can learn something new every day
even if you get you know clowned on
stream so
well the only thing that could go wrong
here now is reign missing back rank
so it's on the board um as a god mature
would say
on the board will he stop checkmate
yeah i i think that at this level he
will
i mean i i just these are the
final few participants of the event
queenie one is a very there it is
nice bishop v2 i don't like that he
hasn't created a fort for his king but i
don't i also don't think he's gonna hang
backrank mate
yeah no i don't i don't think he will
either by the way brain was very proud
of the hat that he bought he showed me
in last night's lesson um he said if he
started to lose
he was gonna he was gonna rip off his
shirt
and just like focus on just the hat on
the screen like try to intimidate the
kid
he asked me if he thought if i thought
that would intimidate his opponent i
said no
well danny it's like it's like a speech
championship right like
we pan to any gm and it's just this
right like
we call it the fabicam the forehead cam
yeah exactly that's that that's
you guys watch any gm on camera that's
what they're
they're under the screen it's amazing
and you've been a part of those tech
sessions it's always so funny because
we're like
all right are you sure this is where
you're gonna be when you're playing yep
all right can you move around a little
bit for me show me how you're gonna be
yep this is where i'm gonna be
the moment the first game starts i'm
completely out of frame
it's like oh dear god here we go again i
think that a lot of them have gotten
better because of the online experience
but it is it is funny
uh okay wow and look at that
it's a great move by rayne i think even
though it wasn't necessary i think he
saw that the rook was pinned
right and so he's getting the queen out
of the way preparing to take
he's in great shape yes i think part of
our getting distracted here is the fact
that
within 15 moves uh white is up a rook
this is the last thing that i expected
i'm not gonna lie but that's what
happens when opening meltdowns happen
and um well really it was it was one it
was just one blunder right if we go it
was knight takes d5
because if you play bishop e6
you know black is i mean like you you i
think you said it well levy you said the
computer still thinks it's equal but we
were already talking about black has the
bishop pair
talking about a5 i mean i personally i i
don't know i feel like the long-term
features of this position could be
better for black because of that but
it's sometimes you make a blunder and we
had this yesterday me and hicari like
you
you make a blunder and then it's like
it's like everything falls apart it was
the
it was the worst blunder you could make
for the position and then this move
is so there you go that's what happened
welcome everyone on chance three
presented by grip6
hey uh so your move order if you if you
take this back
to um to move
to move six so you combined knight f3
with
a3 this idea to expand let's i want to i
want to stay here just to make sure
benji doesn't blunder mate
and then we're going to go back and
answer that fair
because i guess i actually don't know
that i have the answer you want i don't
know that i'm a i'm a french advanced
expert i don't my line is nice e3
but i'll tell you what i what i taught
rain full disclosure
no no i i was okay he he doesn't hang
mate no i was just going to say that
what you taught reign
took benji uh
yeah normally a3 is the move if you're
gonna play it in this order
yes and so what i was going to say i
checked his games i went to opening tree
and like i checked
benji's games the way you taught rain to
play coincidentally
benji's only seen two times out of like
70 games ever
so he wasn't prepared for this he
reacted wrong and at this level when you
react wrong it can snowball
you don't feel confident you don't find
the right ideas dude
it was hilarious about this this only
happened because i don't know the line
well
like i literally was just teaching him
dude you just develop and play a3 i
didn't even think about the move order
wow look at that
ipad right there genius yeah let's uh
all right i uh i feel kind of bad um
i feel kind of bad because this is just
going to be a long conversion process
now now white's going to trade the queen
benji's probably going to play queen g6
but it's it's
you know reigns going to win and i would
be great baseball commentators because
we've been commenting on a lopsided game
for a while and
and i'm having a good time oh it's great
i think i think the truth is that like
we know the result at this level i mean
unless rain just does something
catastrophic so we could talk about we
thought about anything i mean
that's super flower seeds isn't that a
big and he still hasn't freed his back
rank so
i mean yeah blunders happen
i don't know i mean we did see a
completely insane rain wilson in the
second game against moist critical like
that was
that was a but this at this point you're
up
three minutes chill out trade the pieces
don't lose anything don't hang mate
you'll be fine
we know five there you go um
shout out to the uh community
and the viewership we're growing here
the day's just getting started
very good okay this is an awesome
battery set up by benji
and again this is the what you would
love to see
that is that is the most
tight rope walking way to stop that mate
danny you took the words out of my mind
i was about to say what you'd love to
see what you'd love to see right bishop
c3 is the move that's like
dude solve the problem yeah
i mean like g3 we don't even we go to
break like
we don't really okay just like just root
d8 the rook is gone no more back rank
problems if frank wilson hangs back
ranked mate i'll
i don't know i'll give like 500. oh my
god that movie just played
i wasn't expecting it my calves my calf
muscles tightened
i don't even know i have calf muscles
danny i go for a two-minute walk and i
get
how do you still work out in quarantine
you still work dude i'm obsessed with
crossfit it's my only therapy
um but the gym i go to totally socially
distance and safe
what is going on here um everyone gets
their own box
and it's like it's it's away from other
people it's very very cleanly we have to
wipe down all the weights when we're
done it's actually
kind of gross the amount of uh clorox
that goes into keeping that place
covered free
i might be getting sick because of that
but that's a whole other story
oh queen c now rook d7 right rain's done
messing around i mean rain is uh
he sees rook d7 we're shipping it
yeah or queen d7 but yeah rook d7 man
ranges
no back rank yeah there it is all right
he smoked this one that's
he really did that was that was actually
stunning you know i i
i think that benji is a little bit more
solid with white he does his whole ready
with d4 you got prep against that too
uh we didn't look at d4 i thought he
played knight f3
uh yeah he plays like knight f3 then he
delays then he plays
but what rayne does mostly is is a
king's indian setup that's
you've seen his games he plays the d6
stuff is black where he got in big
trouble against charlie
that um you know the he plays like a
pierce kind of thing
that's what rayne does so he's his plan
is pretty much
he's got one trick up his sleeve he's
going to go for it if not i told him go
back to your thing
so we'll see what happens
i mean i would love to i'd love to be in
depth and
analyze the position but i i actually
one thing i just want to point out
i don't want rain to take all the pawns
i actually really respect what sartosh
does when he's winning
like he just he just goes for the kill
like he doesn't care about the other
pieces
and like you know no g3 just queenie's
like queen f7 bishop d2 done clean cut
game is over so why or why i think
sardosh
and i think you would agree or and i
were talking today like that as well as
the fact that he tends to play better
when he plays faster his intuition is so
strong like
the fact that he sometimes you can't
measure that players of all levels
blunder but certainly we know that
there's a lot of blunders in pogchamps
um but the fact that he when he wins he
just cleans up
and the fact that he um oh
speaking of he plays better
yeah that that really was brutal that's
not quite a game that will make you quit
the french defense
but it will definitely make you
reconsider what to play against the
advanced french
uh because yeah that that that game if
anything anybody in the chat who plays
e4
and struggles with the french that was a
game to watch
right there that was that was very
convincing great
okay well that was uh that was a a very
quick win for rayne wilson but we still
have a lot of chess ahead if you're just
tuning in
don't go anywhere we've got game two
coming up between
rayne wilson and benji fishy to decide
who joined sardoche in the championship
bracket
and then of course nico and tubo will
round out the consolation bracket later
today
me and levy rosman will be right back
enjoy hikaru with the break it's pog
champs three presented by grip six
well let's take a look i i know you i'm
almost certain you're debating me but
i'm gonna i'm gonna look anyway
but i'm gonna i'm gonna look anyway oh
wait no let's go back to puzzle rush
sorry i have to go back to puzzles um
so let's keep going with puzzles one sec
oh wait no let's go back to puzzle rush
sorry i have to go back to puzzles um
okay let's let's go back here all right
let's keep rolling
okay but i don't know if
this morning i got a request from a
streamer
known as ludwig on discord for a bot v
bot so he can pair his bot
i.e ludwig versus bots like mr beast you
down for that feature i started a
conversation in slack with
the project team the product team from
computer that sounds like a cool feature
what do you think
i'm i'm down for that it sounds great
it's more apparent
versus wrench and you see what the bots
do
i there was a there was someone i saw
something on twitter somewhere somebody
may have made a chess streamer
tournament like i bought a bot streamer
yeah yeah yeah that was smarter chefs
are uh the stats guy he has
chessgoals.com which is a great site go
to chess girls.com
there you go and i think in the first
round i played uh i played andrea botes
and uh i won but it was uh it was
intense oh i didn't win
i bought it i mean frankly
you know danny i get i get dms from
people who are like why did your bot
play h6 on move one
like i don't know i didn't program it
sorry
my butt my butt is literally the punch
line of thing although i made a joke a
few streams ago
when i see someone like with like an
1100 rating posting that they beat the
daniel wrench bot do i even need to fill
in the blank in terms of what they did
like i mean i love you but
yeah um well there there's this guy who
uh
exploited the feature where if if you
don't refresh the page the bot plays the
same moves
oh so this kid yeah this kid jack uh he
he made a video where he pre-moved like
70 straight moves or something and then
he beat my butt and then he like
recorded my reaction made a big thing
out of it
that is hilarious okay so this is not
quite what we looked at
this is already a transposition note
that benji played knight f3
d5 and d4 so we are we are
reign is on his own i absolve myself of
all influence over the game but i did
tell him this
that if we get a queen spawn okay he
remembered that that's awesome you got
to make sure in a queens pawn game
everybody
that you can take back with a pawn
because you've got to keep that
structure together
you don't want things like this to
happen or your opponent has two pawns in
the center you don't
this is actually theory but we're not
going to get into that the point is
positionally you've really got to
protect
so i'm glad to see rayne remember that
principle he will probably play g6 here
nope he didn't g6 and bishop back is is
kind of what he's familiar with king's
indian stuff so
here we go we'll see yeah he gets the
bishop outside the pawn chain
so i guess he wanted to play e6 now this
is not like great but if black plays e6
it's extremely solid
okay he goes g6 he's playing this like
gotta komski
like the schlectherslaw variation except
he doesn't have a score admission i'm
gonna shorten that last hundred dollar
donor named to t
bird um although i guess i can say turd
bird my kids will probably think it's
funny hey
turd bird turd bird just donated a
hundred bucks way to go turtle bird
of all the things all the things that
get set on the pogchamps broadcast i'm
pretty sure
turd is uh i'm pretty sure it's legal
yeah
we'll be fine so rayne played bishop g4
and takes up three this is obviously
um not a but what i'll do is i'll say
the one line we kind of looked at
is he he wanted to have an idea against
the king's name that if he could
he would play something like this levy
and and and basically play bishop g4
and try to play queen d7 in here and i
think again
you know we were looking at a specific
line that's away from his structure and
i said like very
unlikely you'll get this so remember you
know if and when you transpose go to
positions
play for structures you're familiar with
because you'll be more familiar with the
tactics and the ideas
and so he did kind of ultimately do a
little bit of both here right he played
bishop g4 which isn't super common
but g6 is obviously very solid and now
black is in you know this is a very
equal game
yeah if if he remembers kind of the
ideas of the king's indian
which is in many positions to play the
move e5 you know he can set that up but
i think really the best move here for
black is
is yeah that and now you know black says
i've traded my light squad bishop but i
have all these pawns on the light
squares
i'll just play a6 and then like you know
i'll complete the mythical quest
of all pawns on light squares uh but
benji is really good at these positions
he likes b3 bishop b2
slow development and then later expand
with e4 he's in his wheelhouse so
okay and as i say that he plays that
move so
i think this shows he has the plan that
you're talking about living he's aware
that he needs to strive for e4 i'm with
you he needs to complete development
first
benji you got to develop and maybe even
put rooks in the center first don't
don't be in a rush to play e4 um right
but but i think he has that idea in mind
well i think bishop d3 was a really
important loss of tempo because yeah
like there was no need to go bishop d3
he should have just
and now right now if rain plays c5 man
this
is no you're right actually that's right
bad or positive i'm officially rooting
for benji in this game we want overtime
we want free chips we want pizza too
i would love some pizza i had pizza last
night at 2 a.m that's why i love new
york city
yeah that's why i'm also gaining too
much weight but
it was it was amazing man pepperoni
right out the right out the oven oh
so good oh my god rain rain's in his own
today i can feel it yeah you're seeing
the board well e5 is a great move
benji i'm that one it's insane danny
that like i heard you say this to hikari
yesterday
we're talking about one maneuver or one
pawn move
in pog champs it's one move bishop d3
and all of white's chances to get an
advantage were gone because he he
coordinated his pieces the wrong way
no and it shows you know you're
following up on what mina carl was
saying it's it's it shows how far we've
come i mean these guys
are all um
you know not to say that any of the
players in the beginning pog champs even
if they were more beginner level that it
wasn't the same kind of authentic
everyone's trying to get better at chess
experience
but it really does show that you know
when you have people going full half oo
and you got sardosh on the grind right
and then you've got players
like rain wilson and benji fishy i think
from the very beginning benji
rayne and sardosh have clearly been the
top guys
by the way taking d5 was a really good
response by benji this is not going to
be that clear at all
yeah so you don't need to take what just
got moved because then you would have
gotten your queen and bishop forks which
is the whole reason bishop d3 was
such a problem is that you don't you
didn't need to make that move your
bishop was
not really changing too much you know
what the computer is suggesting here
c5 by black which just looks like a
mouse lip
that's the best move and then it wants
knight a4
and that's why is so deceiving get ready
for this eval bar to go nuts everybody
because i don't think see
and here you go rain plays queen e7 so
as soon as we were plotting e5 and i
think it was rightfully so i think rain
is seeing the board well and he clearly
saw this idea
but the truth is it may have been a
little bit of a too advanced follow-up
because now
now he's going to get himself in trouble
yeah d take c6 now benji's got to get
that tunnel vision i
benji's got to realize e4 is not a
threat which i think is why he played
bishop d3 he was so worried about the e4
square
but there's no threat like right you're
fine just take the pawn
take the ball probably don't take twice
because a rook will come to c8 and hit
the night and
maybe it works i haven't gone fully car
here and actually you know calculated
but
now rain is now rain is going off the
deep end here
oh man rain's gone wild i think they
both had just miscalculated the pieces
on that square
yeah that's it and the problem is that
now black is down three pawns
just like that i mean okay so bishop d3
was genius
i mean what was it you said at the break
you said benji's much more solid as
white even if he made the small step
there i think that this is um
okay brain was down almost a rook
against charlie right and came back in
drew to hold his match
so you know i think he's i think he's a
stronger player and he shouldn't give up
but i think more than likely this is
looking like benji's game right now
yeah now reigns well he's got to take
the bishop but i think that at that
point benji's probably going to take
with the queen
just like you know right off his
instinct is yes trade the queen
i'm up pawns um what you showed earlier
like if we go back before reign played
e4
yeah uh although now he takes on c6 so
he's uh it's a
it's a avalanche now getting in trouble
but yeah it takes
i think takes could have been met by
this but yeah
peter says white's fine here i don't
even know i think knight d5 yeah
that's it yeah
but maybe well i was gonna say maybe
rain saw that but clearly
that was not his ideas idea was that e4
and
that was sadly a bad idea and sometimes
in chess bad ideas result in
a lot of loss and in this case it's a
lot of pawns
yeah still tricky obviously obviously
black's in big trouble the other thing
he's also down on time so
one thing you got to give kudos to benji
is like that first game
that first game was bad right he got he
got his butt kicked in the french
but but the mindset he comes back with
here i mean he's he's playing fast he's
playing confident it shows that he's not
rattled and so
um
yeah i think it's it's it's important
for a guy like benji like when you lose
a game like that
you're just like what did i do wrong oh
i made that one wrong pawn capture in
the in the opening okay let's go
next time i know what i'm supposed to do
so that's it
memory loss oh it's so useful in chess
except i still remember
i know dumb moves i play football like
well and maybe you're maybe
i i shouldn't say that maybe you're like
no danny we're nothing alike but what
i'll say
is i i'm definitely a streaky player so
the problem with that is like when
things are going well
they can go really well right but when
you can't let go of mistakes a lot of
the times
you know you go and you go into those
like you're playing against the ghosts
of your past
right and and so it's easier said than
done but i do think all the great
all the great white says that all the
great white sharks right in any sport
have short-term memory loss you know and
they they just smell blood in the water
they don't remember their mistakes and
that's what they do i read that term in
a
book called talent is overrated great
book and he talks about the great white
shark mentality and his short-term
memory loss
yeah i uh i should probably like buy
that book
who's the author i love the title
because i'm like oh talent is overrated
that means i have a chance
that's what yeah that's what i'm saying
who's the author i'm gonna look this uh
i've already googled enough things by
the way a4 is a wonderful move bishop a3
is a wonderful move yeah it not only
threatens a5 it threatens bishop a3
what a weird match i mean this could be
like two games of just lopsided chess
here
yeah a4 is great what an amazing idea
like in a position full of pawns and
bishops and
queen and knight he finds a pawn move
like see he wants to play three and
good kid man he's really good
you can play bishop b5 and save i mean
that's probably the best bishop b7
obviously if you're if you're going if
you're into that kind of thing right if
you're
attacking brooks on the back rank now
some people are into that
that's a move yeah because yeah it's
definitely a move
definitely move the good thing is you're
at least defended so you don't really
worry about if the rook moves up and
attacks you but yeah for the most part
you probably should avoid
very simple one move attacking moves
that don't do too much but in this case
gets your bishop out of the way or out
of danger she don't go d5
i'm gonna d5 you lose the game with d5
maybe so
well the problem with d5 obviously if it
trades pieces but you know you don't
want to create
but no d5 is not a bad move at all right
i mean it's a
way to get some pieces off the board
it's uh
my concern was the a1 rook i don't want
him to open the diagonal just completely
forget so
replays but should be five yeah queen
takes b3
takes b3 action a little bit a little
bit back in the game you still got to
worry about bishop a3
but at this point you just got to get
some material back so you should
probably take and then
cross your fingers
it's two pawns up now i mean you know
it's still a game man because it's
white's advantage is in the fact that
white is up two pawns
but it you don't feel it always because
the more pawns there that have been
traded the more open the lines are so
you
right everything's open it's all open
all
all over the place yeah you're right and
these are two pawns but they're also
like you know they're not the they're
not the most dangerous pawns yet you
know you advance them up the board
that's one thing but they're not
they're not like a two-pass pawn
advantage against nothing on the queen
side so this is going to take some
coordination
gonna take some technique for benji for
sure
in positions like this it's very often
you you don't yeah like you don't need
to play a move like that because now the
queen just goes exactly back to where it
was and
what have you done you kind of put your
rook on a weird square so or even
right queen b4 but yeah that would
threaten rook scene one i think that's a
little bit advanced
but you're right this is you get
yourself in trouble when you start
putting pieces on squares they don't
belong
you know even if it's not a blunder yet
that stuff adds up comes back to bite
you
as they say that stuff comes back with
you not everything stays in vegas
okay i
i wouldn't know um only times i've ever
been in vegas
uh i played chess there in uh 2019
yeah um yeah but i i i'm
i was just there like solo yeah i'm like
i've been i've spent more time
in casinos for someone who has never
actually gambled
i spend more time in concedos maybe than
any other human
did you just watch what were you like
playing chess raised you know chess
tournaments you know on the west coast
you're going to vegas all the time
you know yeah one of my craziest vegas
experiences is going to sound like super
like
mild but um the millionaires just
end with a white tiger and you're at
mike tyson's house no no
it ends with me you know i was 19 my
first
nine with it with a knife yep no joke i
stayed at the travel lodge in vegas
which like you know
all these resorts but i was like a kid
and i was like i'm going to go play a
chess tournament i want to save money so
i walked every day to planet hollywood
and i had to walk through the casino to
make it to the
yeah it was wild i couldn't step off of
the carpet you know what i mean like on
the casino if you step out yeah
you're uh in your lane kid you're not
21. um
yep yep okay by the way rain rain is
avoiding trades which
this is a this is a good idea i think
conceptually when you're like
i'm losing i need to keep the pieces on
the board but rook
cd8 is actually a big mistake if benji
sees bishop a3
because this rook here is running out of
squares um oh it looks like benji has
played a5
and knight b5 so that was that was a
missed opportunity from benji
bishop a3 would have been pretty nice
and that's what the computer liked
um rook c6 now probably just to tag the
queen
but yeah white is still better let's put
it this way
not too much has changed and the time
keeps ticking so
something's got to happen soon right and
and now benji is down on the clock so we
were praising him earlier for being in
the right mindset
short-term memory loss you're up on the
clock
oh yeah man that is a fancy move but
very unnecessary that's a move that
gives a coach a little bit of a you can
if you listen closely you can hear young
lugma hammer
squeezing his teddy bear for comfort
like if white's queen is on g3 here
that could have been a disaster because
the knights of three knights show the
imaginary tactic if the queen is here
taking giving up your queen and then
taking e2
with a fork down on the on the king and
queen over here so
um would have been imagination of a
camera i'm sure you're lurking
watching waiting judging a lot like my
wife just sitting there
in the shadows how's the teddy bear
buddy tell me in chat
he's uh he he's been live and i think
he's been watching
his uh his protege sorry everyone go
over to twitch.tv
slash gmj's j l h
give him a follow yes did you just
compare your your wife to you ludwig
camera i'm still like
i was looking for a follow-up i couldn't
i couldn't think of one i'm just i'm
just
making sure i heard that right um who
should be offended in that case probably
probably it's complicated right a lot
like uh amber's relationship status
all right let's let's listen into hammer
actually it's kind of a rare thing we
can do so we're gonna
we're gonna cue him up and uh i don't
know how long we'll be able to stand
this but let's see as long as we can
right
benji gives away the bishop that was his
plan with the previous move
now dealing with the threat against his
rook
uh fortunately he has a very nice way of
dealing
with that because he can move his rook
up
and then that rook is protected and it's
protecting
this guy it's protected by that guy
and it's putting pressure against this
guy
so benji has a now starting to find some
harmony
with his pieces yeah i agree
there you go camera's a pretty good
chess commentator
yeah you know i i think hammer
is like the first person on earth to
pronounce every letter in every word
he just has like the way he he talks he
just
every he just talks perfectly like i
don't know he has like a very
perfect way right he doesn't you know
he's no person no he's just like
very precise like he just i want him to
coach me on anything how to assemble
a piece of furniture i want him to stand
there and be like all right now you've
got
for those who don't know and as
sometimes we say things in chat i
understand chat you're like you know
don't ask us to understand your inside
jokes dandy so i get it i'm not trying
to defend but i'm you know we're good
i'm good friends with hammer
and he's actually very well known he may
be the face of commentary in norway for
those who don't know
childhood friends with magnus carlsen uh
was actually his second
when magnus won his first world
championship title and hammer does
commentary for tv2
uh in norway which is a a big
uh private uh broadcasting corporation
and they cover chess most people think
of nrk
but um anyway so hammer is a fantastic
chess commentator jokes aside and
he is worth a follow if you want to do
it um but okay
this game is coming back we do need to
buckle up here we've got two and a half
minutes
approaching for benji and reign to his
credit like he did against charlie
uh levy he was losing out of the opening
but this is still an absolute mess
that is a really good move
super good because it was maybe the only
way to guard both pieces here
you've got well there's roo k2 but rook
a2 is kind of a gross move like i don't
know
it finds the equal danger and now yeah
that's super clutch very very clutch by
benchy now benji's competed in like
massive
you know fortnite tournaments it's
obviously not the same chess
is very uh slow-paced compared to that
but your time is constantly ticking it's
a very different type of adrenaline
the adrenaline's huge i mean rain was
saying last night he's like man i feel
like i'm like
20 worse as a player when i play in
front of so many people he's like i know
that surprised you because i'm an actor
but it's different like when so many
people are watching me
live live viewing is different than
recording like oh yeah you know what i
mean
and he was like saying like i'm so
nervous when i'm playing
and i'm like dude i understand and i
said well if it makes you feel any
better
you're playing in the most viewed chess
tournament of all time so no pressure
straight up by the way like that that
that that is amazing i um
dare i not compare my improv
extracurricular activity freshman year
of college
uh to you know dwight
like it's so it's so good you show up we
showed up for five hours every sunday to
record 6 p.m to 11 p.m it was on the
west side
manhattan you show up you eat food you
hang out you know you talk a little
banter with your your friends you record
stuff cut action this this this you're
gone
like streaming's very different i mean
in my in the speech championship
it's nerves man the heart rate is up
even when before you're playing so i get
it
i totally get it well rain is keeping
this close
benji now at two minutes and 20 seconds
but if the a5 pawn falls there it goes
yeah this is still still
anyone's game and actually remember all
rain needs is a draw
to punch his ticket to the championship
so we are all rooting for benji we want
overtime here
but but the advantage has slipped away
you know if he finds an idea like 93 95
though right now now what he needs to do
levy is use the
dynamic duo the queen and the knight to
create something against the king over
here
yes the only two pieces that if you
combine them hold all the powers i mean
they can't you know
take uh right they can't promote when
they get to the end but
um he's gotta not fall behind too much
on time
with our forces combined we are captain
planet that's a great move by the way
he's headed to b7
that's such a good move such a good move
and he has king h2 so his king is always
safe
yep that little forward
no despite that apon falling i feel like
benji is
he's in a he's in a hard position to
blunder right like look at it
everybody's protected
he's got very um a very good piece set
meaning the pieces
as levy said they work well together and
if he's got his eyes
on the prize of f7 i think this is going
to be
super hard for rain i'm trying to
predict what rain is thinking like
he obviously sees rook b7 i'm thinking
he'll go rook d7 but then rook b8 and
now you have a whole new set of problems
or will he play like queen a6 or queen
c7 just not letting it but again you run
into more problems queen c7 knight d5
so what is he going to do
and he doesn't even mean is like queen
a2 and he doesn't find it queen a2 would
have been a move that like defends
wow but benji's backing up why didn't he
play rook b7
i think he'd be mentally prepared
queenie too i think at this point you
start preparing moves you're like if he
does this
i'm just snap off a move because rook b7
of course
yeah rook b7 would have been better he
was worried about queenie one
i think queenie one rook b7 but there's
nothing there
right checks checks are for kids right
you gotta remember it's just a check and
now
now this is actually just waiting for
white
i was going to say danny computer wants
queen f3 so once you just go back and
say
i messed up you know
you know you went the wrong way when the
computer would rather you go right back
to that square but
benji is still i think one thing we'll
say from a technique perspective if
benji kind of has his eyes like let me
go win this pawn
if he can do it if he can get rid of
that pawn then he's in a position
you know but i think he'll win um
he wants rook a1 i guess like or queen
b3
yeah maybe or queen b6
queen b6 now b6 is spicy
what does black play on queen b6 you
almost have to probably like
we need eight what do you sell it
because actually
rook b8 rook be it rebirth oh my gosh
it's hilarious we're both just missing
it
rook b8 jesus rook b8 wow because in my
mind i was like you have to keep the
bishop protected no you just you give
that bishop straight up that's how the
evil
goes the other way boys and girls just
watching danny and levy do commentary
um iams do it better who needs
i mean gm's are too perfect i mean it's
like it's like you know art 100
where oh i don't like that oh i don't
like that
huge mistake knight h5 knight h5 or any
knight move this is not a move the rain
wants to play that is terribly weakening
to his king side
oh knight h5 just sneak in oh man
the thing that is a minute night h5 is
now you've got back rank threats
um yeah g7 is covered oh god it's
too wrong that's too sober of a move
you need to get weird with it i almost
wonder if benji's just a little i don't
want to say intimidating
he's a little nervous right i feel like
he knows rayne is the strongest player
he's faced yet
and he's not playing as aggressive as we
saw him clean up some of the other
matches he had right i mean i feel like
he's playing a little timid here
was that a slip or does he want to play
a5 rook b8 there was really
good but okay rook 8 is fine as well
yeah this is surgical now will rain
realize
he can trade queens and push the pawn
it's actually his best move even though
ironically
okay and he doesn't does that ironically
he takes and here comes a5 and now if
you're benji
oh no he doesn't know a5 e4 just go e4
e5
oh wrong pawn neither player is using
their pawn advantage
use your pawn advantage yeah guys come
on oh man all right e4 all right take h5
take h5 play e4 e4 e5
okay remember we're here we're here for
the uh
for the long time not necessarily the
good times we're only giving commentary
to help
their understanding no no criticism we
know it's hard to be under a minute
that's what i'm saying but yes neither
player has
to yet use it but a5 is the first
the first real threat to do so it's so
hard to keep your nerves here as white
yeah you're gonna go all in
i think rain's gonna take and play a4
but that would actually probably just be
be wrong because e i'll put e6 a3 oh my
god what a crazy move because
actually if benji goes for e6 instead of
coming back he could lose
yeah okay if benji plays e6 instead of
coming
he back actually lose the game but rook
f7 king g8
how do you i don't think you can get
back oh smack okay this was the best
move i think from a practical
perspective too like
he realizes he can stop the pawn levy
and he's even in a position
to like run over and get it with the
king in theory because he's got a big
majority here like
that might even work
king g4 now wrong way okay i
think king of five in veggie wins the
game he played it i think benji is going
to win this game and we're going to have
overtime kids
does reign find rook a5 only move
so that if king g5 i guess at least wow
f4
but then gf but then gs or
maybe stay patient e4 then
f6 right as long as he takes with the e
pawn
if the longest benji takes with the epod
i think he's still
aha okay oh good move by benji
this is insanity wow
this is a real rook ending ladies and
gentlemen
let me let me look at these guys playing
good stuff right the rook is properly
balancing defensive measures along the
ranks
you know benji is properly shielding his
king while he advances the pawns
man diverescue
indeed this is wild that pawn activity
and you know despite white having the
extra pawn the rook is just
the terrible it's terrible situation for
the the pawn was up like one rank or
even two ranks on a5
white has serious chances but you can
never move the rook because a2
and oh man where you described that i
realized you're
right this might be hard for me okay
that was a big mistake by reign
i don't i don't know that reign will
realize he needs to give up the a pawn
to trade it for the f1 he has to find
things like rook a4
uh oh no
i think he's still i think it's good i
mean king b3 king e4
oh you're right you're in time in fact
you might lose
oh my gosh rain's gonna save it same way
he did with charlie
crazy i thought there's nothing i mean
the pawns just yeah now king e5 now
black is winning no
oh no wow
oh no oh my gosh
brain's winning the king upon ending
unbelievable benji can do only benji can
only draw oh it's a draw now
yeah but it's it doesn't it's over i
know oh
i know he's gonna say joshua chamberlain
strikes again
it's uh yeah he was winning and then he
had to actually you know
it's never too late but i think rain
doesn't really care because yeah
obviously he can't win just for the king
so
oh man the cinderella story man like
winning the group the only man to have
beaten start ocean i hit the head but
we're not going to get to see the
rematch
yeah it's funny because benji's probably
a tougher matchup for sardoche i don't
know how well reigned will handle
litz against sardoche but if it goes to
an overtime tiebreaker but
wow what a heartbreaker for benji he was
totally winning in game two
not what you saw coming
no absolutely not but uh i i really hope
he doesn't
he doesn't uh stop playing chess i mean
well i mean he's not going to quit what
i'm just saying is like
she's one of the players in twitch
rivals coming up by the way um
which oh awesome yeah
our partnered obligatory shout out but
we'll do one that isn't required twitch
rivals on march 2nd going to be pretty
awesome i know that
uh levy roswell will be there but benji
is is one of the confirmed participants
on march 2nd for twitch rivals hand and
brain chest style
so yes his growth's been unbelievable
i think he's caught up to being one of
the best players in the field in
a month and a half i mean imagine what
happens in a year might be like 1800.
all right well we'll see if rain
finishes the job or
gives us gives us a a clippable
stalemate stephen
i don't know that rain is uh
king a6 king c6 maybe 16.6 is the recipe
you need
they'll mate stephen it is he might he
might do it for the content but
for content he might do it for the
content
he's thinking about doing it for the
content he's not thinking how to mate
here it for the content rain
eclipse can only be a minute long oh
queen c6
let's go leave me a minute
i really should learn how to do that end
game
no uh
uh i should have been able to to meet
you there i just
i should have taken my time wow what a
game
jeez all right
well that just happened
and uh we're we're gonna be back with
more things that just happened here
and uh more things are gonna happen
um let's keep it happening
hey peter what what's happening
all right we'll be back um i might i
might be uh
flashing rain a red card i'm gonna pop
out of this grip six wallet pretty sweet
uh we'll be right back for pogchamps in
just a moment
drive benji into stream for an interview
no
uh maybe we'll listen to the interview
on chess.com
but yeah benji's going to be so upset
right now
sardoche will be happy yeah he
definitely will
never playing to getting to the
semifinals is impressive nonetheless
yeah
benji put in a lot of effort but
it still feels bad when the effort isn't
rewarded
today he was kind of the he was his own
worst enemy
because once he got this advantage of
three pawns
he just he was so obsessed with trading
that he didn't like he didn't consider
any aggressive possibilities
whatsoever he was all about making as
many trades as possible
and that kind of came back to bite him
especially this trade here
because when he had his rook in the
middle he was still protecting his own
pawn
and so he was chilling at this moment
but once he makes the trade it's
impossible to keep this pawn protected
and that's part of that was like part of
the reason
it it all came fell apart also here
he could have been aggressive he could
have tried to go for the checkmate
against black's king
but instead he he just wanted to trade
he wanted to trade and even in this
situation
uh ma even though he wanted to get the
trades
it wasn't when you're a pawn up you're
no longer guaranteed to win the end game
and rain made you know rain made some
mistakes
the pawn up here benji could have gone
for the attack against the king
but benji wasn't in an attacking mindset
he just
he wanted to make trades this could have
been a sweet finish to the game
where benji could have sacrificed the
queen
with the with the knight and and rook
working together for the checkmate
but yeah i guess it wasn't meant to be
today unfortunately
uh miles thank you so much for uh
gifting the sub
to stormloop thank you so much mouse
and miles coming in with another five
gifted uh
to lyle lyell richtor traxo
and tails thank you so much miles
sad yeah i'm a bit sad right now
because one thing is if he loses against
a better player
but today he didn't really lose to a
better player he lost
to his own nerves in my opinion
which you know it can be interpreted as
harsh but
benji is a competitor no one puts more
higher standards to themselves than
competitors
and uh benji's gonna be very unhappy
about his
his performance today inexperienced
streamer coming in with a sub thank you
so much
and we are back here with more pog
champs three presented by grip six
our last semi-final just decided with
rain wilson
punching his ticket into the
championship but benji starting with you
i know this didn't
go the way you you wanted it to today
but a super close match
and uh what were your thoughts on on
where it got away for you or any of your
takeaways from this
um i don't know i think i don't think it
was no i mean
the first game i just made a stupid
blunder and i
rayne played really good i couldn't it
was really hard for me to come back
um in the second game uh i was winning
and then
the time pressures got to me and i yeah
started panicking a bit
um that was basically it for me but the
rain played
played
and i were wondering about that because
you were winning in the second game
right and then there were some moments
where
you started playing super fast was that
what was going on just the nerves of the
time pressure
hard to keep pushing on the advantage
yeah yeah i think that was it i was just
whenever i get below like 30 seconds i
start to panic a lot and
yeah that was basically what costed me
but
you know is what it is yeah i guess my
my question for rain was going to be how
do you
how are you able to make it so dramatic
like that second game you always seem to
be fighting back and
we've seen this style with everybody
ludwig loses the first game then he
comes back you
in the second game like to go down
material for some reason
how do you how do you overcome that like
how do you you stabilize what is it
about the mentality or do you just kind
of play the board
range muted hold on
oh
uh yeah the first game was about as
solid as game as i've
played in a long time and i felt really
good about that and he
blundered and gave up his bishop there
and then kind of got on the ropes and
had
pieces forked so i did get a little
lucky there
but it was a solid game and the second
game
um i don't know he had um
it was something i just wasn't used to
that
uh the way the center was locked up and
it's one of those things where you have
to be like how much pressure is on each
pawn like i've got a knight on the pawn
and a bishop on a pawn and a queen on a
pawn
and i've got this pawn on the pawn and
and i just
lost track of of that and in my head i
saw this fork i was like
oh there's a fork with the queen and the
bishop and but i didn't even have the
fork it wasn't even real because his
knight was there so i don't know what i
was thinking but i just
my brain just kind of shut down in that
little middle part of the game
in the second game and then um and then
and then
i'm like listen he's up three points um
uh i think i play a little faster than
he does so let me just
hang in there solid as long as i can and
maybe pawn by pawn claw my way up
back which i did for a large chunk of it
and then he got a really good endgame
strategy
and if he had rammed those pawns down my
king's throat i would have been
dead as a doornail um but um
i got lucky because of the time pressure
as well and then at the end
danny you never taught me how to mate
with a king and a queen against a cage
i knew you were going to blame me and
blame me for that
that's what you teach five-year-olds
when they're learning chess and i don't
know it's danny's fault people were like
rain is so strong he should know how to
check me with the king and queen i'm
like i agree that should not be on me
i mean you you should have this one okay
okay well i gotta
listen i put a wrench in it i gotta have
it right
did you get that yeah i did good i wanna
ask benji a question
um benji you so when you were playing uh
your first game i took a look at you
know your your rating progress chart and
everything you've had your chest.com
account since 2018.
um a lot of us you know you we we saw
you beat stardust to nothing keep your
nerves better
in that match kind of two questions for
you number one
like how how have you gained 550 points
in a month like how much do you work on
your chest
and number two like where do you see
your potential do you have any like goal
beyond this event like i mean obviously
you wanted to win i'm sure you felt
confident enough to win but
so what's your goal do you have a rating
goals how much do you work on your chest
period and
do you have a future goal for like a
certain elo um
yeah i mean i mean i started i started
playing chess i mean i played a bit as a
kids but never like anything serious
um so i knew like how the pieces moving
stuff but i started playing about two
months ago
for like the first time since since i
was like five
um and yeah i was grinding like every
day
um and then you know i saw pogchamps
obviously i've seen i've seen the past
pogchamps um i was like enough to get an
invite to this
um and that's you know i'm a competitive
guy so i put a lot of time into
it like an hour or two a day um just
working on puzzles working on um just
playing um
and then obviously getting coached by
hammer has helped
a ton i definitely wouldn't have got
here without getting coached by him um
yeah he's been he's been a massive help
um yeah i've been playing a lot and
uh like yeah as i said two hours a day i
think i i still want to play chess off
this you know this is not gonna it's not
gonna end
i wanna continue playing this as a hobby
i really enjoy it and you know hopefully
you know i want to start working towards
the the 1500s 1600s
uh eventually um so yeah
i don't really see the stuffing anywhere
you're playing in twitch rivals in a
couple days right march 2nd so it's uh
yeah it's not just yet yeah yeah rain is
it the hat
that brought you the good luck today i
mean you want to talk about that a
little bit
it's a hat yeah okay yeah it's all about
the hat
it's all about the hat danny um
yeah i um i was like you know
i need a cool [ __ ] chess hat
how's that gonna go down so i went to my
old friend etsy she has a store online
and i found this bad boy it took them
forever
i wanted to wear it for the whole thing
took them like three weeks to get to me
now they're going to sell your welcome
vendor whoever you are
you're gonna sell about a thousand chess
wars hats for all the nerds
just for my nerd cred anyway uh
but listen benji is one quarter my age
and equal my skill and he's really
[ __ ] good
and dude i mean you you if you
you will absolutely beat me in the next
podcast
there's no question about it um you have
far more raw talent than i do and i'm
i'm a very very old man in fact i'm way
too old to be doing this
this [ __ ] with all these twitch
streamers
have you learned your kecks and your
your pepe laughs and whatnot are you
did you you're just here to play chess i
don't even know
i don't even know what that is i barely
know how to check my email
yeah but you do know how good sardosha
is because we've talked about that right
i mean so what are you looking ahead to
the final obviously that's tomorrow
what are your uh what are your what are
your own words of coaching for yourself
for that match tomorrow
oh it's tomorrow i'm busy tomorrow shoes
um yeah i saw him play ludwig
and um boy he was good oh i thought it
was gonna be the other way i thought
you were gonna say it was bad and okay
yeah he he he played he played great
against ludwig and
he he really understands spacing on the
board and
you know positional chess and tactical
chess and where to attack and
lines of attack and he he's he's he's
going to be a very
um difficult adversary well benji
you beat sardosh2o so any advice for
rain
um he does get a bit nervous uh at least
i think he did against me but
maybe he's fixed that um but well you
you make people nervous i mean that face
is intimidating
yeah i i i hope so he's he's really good
he's really good
i will be it will be a good final all
right guys well
um thank you so much for for joining us
and again benji thanks for playing
podcamps we knew but it was a close call
because you're a you're a professional
fortnight player uh straight streamer
but you know now now maybe the future of
being a
professional podchamps player might be
on the horizon too you were awesome man
seriously and it was it was inspiring to
watch
where you went like levy said 500 points
i haven't gained 500 points in
ever danny don't talk about it we don't
talk about my rating on this show
because it's not going anywhere good but
rain
way to go man good luck tomorrow in the
final versus sardosh we'll see you then
and uh thanks thanks both guys
thank you thanks guys bye guys thank you
all right well there we go we had our
two players
join us and that is the two players that
will be playing in tomorrow's final
rain versus sardosh you know one of the
things about rayne and obviously he's a
super
um you know kind of jokes around about
it but he's been playing chess for a
long time and i wonder
about the the experience factor versus
like
the grind of of the of like the recent
history factor and i was trying to touch
on this a little bit with
carl levy but i love your thoughts too
the the idea that i think sometimes rain
has a little more experience because
he's been
he's been bouncing between 1100 and 1300
for 25 years right it's different than
than rising
from zero to 1400 and i wonder if
sometimes that just pays off
in some of these matches uh you know i
want to say yes and no but we can't
discredit the fact that you know benji's
uh first of all he's he's younger he's
got better nerves
uh and uh he can manage his adrenaline
better and also like this kid
you know like he plays one of the most
intense games in front of the you know
he's he's signed he's a 16 year old 17
year old kid who's he
signed to already play one of the most
competitive video games if not the most
competitive video game on earth so
i i honestly feel like it was uh
it was a heavyweight knockout in that
first in that first game
meaning that first you ran that lopsided
yeah you're right
like if you ran it ten times man i feel
like that could have been five five and
he got
or four six six four he he got the one
wrong start to the game so
but that's how the cookie crumbles but
i'm excited because i think long term
he's got the highest growth trajectory
possible
that's what i think he's very talented i
think you're i think you're right
and i think um i mean he he's the only
guy that beat sardosh
so far and he beat him 2-0 and you're
right i think that in in hindsight
looking at it it was that
that you know just french gone wrong
right which should be a lesson to all
french players to just stop playing the
french i think that's the message we got
out of this that's the message
uh i well right you gotta we gotta we
got a frenchman in the final who doesn't
even play the french she plays the
sicilian okay so he goes to italy for
his openings
right and i and then we got rain wilson
and um
what a final it's gonna be let's talk a
little bit about what's coming up here
in just a second
we've got nico versus tebow the winner
of that will meet michelle carrey in the
final
um again also also an interesting
match up i think i feel like given some
of the things i've seen tubo do i want
to say like maybe
a slight nod but nico when she's got it
when she's got it rolling she plays
faster and
and and her intuition is really on point
at times with how to play certain
positions in fact sometimes
that becomes the weakness so she plays
too fast but your thoughts on who you
would who you would give the slight nod
to before we dive into the consolation
semi-final
i i it's so tough to choose because if
honestly if nico
took a little bit of time in the open
and got some openings uh
kind of in her in her in her toolbox for
chess she'd be she'd be she'd be easy a
thousand
but she needs to make it out of the
first five ten moves
to get that that flow and tubbo needs to
kind of not get nervous like like [ __ ]
like he he's gotta like absorb that and
be like wait a minute you know or
he's got to punish those opening
mistakes in the first five ten moves but
if it gets out into the
kind of middle game the time like you
said uh
and the kind of positions that nico
seems to be good at with the openings of
the bishops and the knights
i gotta give a very slight nod to her
probably but it's
so tough to choose but i'm excited it's
coming up
well they got to maintain their nerves
they gotta look for blunders out of the
openings avoid time pressure they also
got to make sure that they've got the
energy they need with their favorite
yerba mate is regenerative it's been
around for 25 years
it is also interesting just like reigns
chessylo
it's right it's been it's been the same
for 25 years
and uh i hope rayne's listening to that
hey you said that i didn't say that i
you said it
rain it was him he said it uh guyaki
urbamate uh you can spam the emotes and
chat they're giving away cases it's a
lot of fun
we really do appreciate their support of
course in all our sponsors
uh because they're they're helping make
these events even more awesome
and giving away cool stuff to the
community so use your emote spam it
for a chance to win some cases of guyaki
herbal mate
well we are going to be right back with
more pogchamps 3 presented by grip6 in
just a few moments
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
that pinned onto my board for years that
that picture was the photo i looked at
every day for years and years and years
oh i think we are on the chess.com live
show so we're talking about
our journeys with michelle and i was
just saying that
um my biggest dream was to to get into
the olympic team i wanted to be a chess
olympian
and and i had this photograph of me as a
12 year old with the olympic symbol and
it was on my wall and it
it motivated me every day to keep going
because
chess is a game i really loved as a kid
but it's not just
playing you have to show up at the
lessons you need to go to the chess club
you need to train
and you need to you need to also take
defeats um in a gracious way and realize
that
every game you lose is actually a very
valuable learning lesson
so instead of being upset on how how
poorly i lost
i always i think i was trying to take it
as it's part of the learning process and
just
keep growing and keep improving from
from one's mistakes to do it better next
time to not commit the same mistakes and
it felt amazing to actually go get into
the olympic team because just because
you put a picture on your wall
as a kid it doesn't mean it will become
true it doesn't mean that suddenly your
goal will materialize but
i think it helped me a lot with
motivation to
to know what i want to achieve so that
for me in chess that was the biggest but
once i got onto the team maybe i should
have had another big goal because i
i from then on i didn't have any other
like
huge milestone i want to achieve i there
are titles in chess
so i had i had the titles too on my
board
the woman international master the woman
grandmaster the international master but
i i for instance never thought that i
could become a grandmaster and maybe i
should have been more ambitious maybe i
should have
set out the goal i won the highest title
in chess
um but i didn't maybe maybe i i should
have
aimed even higher but the olympic team
was a
big deal for me and now what's big deal
for me is that there's so many of you
who come into
the chess world and what you were saying
is that you really like the game of
chess and you really like our chess
community you like
you like your stay here and you you feel
welcome then this is a very positive
experience to you and i think nowadays
these are
what what i consider kind of an
accomplishment not just from me but the
community
that that we are doing something that
that's meaningful
yeah wow i feel like i'm learning so
much about you i'm glad we're getting
this time just to
hang out and and watch jess and and get
to know each other even more because
obviously we have a relationship as
student coach um we have a stream which
is really cool
sorry michelle i'm interrupting you
there but i realized it was a stream
stream caption because i was watching
chess.com and they were watching
our stream so it was like an infinite
infinite stream but i was so lost in my
thought process that
i didn't think about the tech side
apologies there chance.com team i will
i'll not do that the matrix
which show is the real one but
also for you michelle so now that you
are
you said that you've done so many
physical challenges for your serious
challenge accepted but this is the first
actual very very mentally challenging
goal that you set out that you wanted to
train as a chess professional and how
far you can
introducing the grip 6 belt the only
belt on the market with the no
gut pinch guarantee the grip 6 is so
light and thin that you'll barely even
notice it's there
it's smooth low profile design makes
this belt the most comfortable belt in
the world
overly confident much you're damn right
because on top of being the most
comfortable belt in the universe
each grip 6 belt comes with our a3 gear
and damn tee
meaning if you don't like any belt for
any reason at any time or in any
condition
you can just contact us and we'll give
you a full refund
and we are back here with pogchamps 3
presented by grip6 remember the limited
time
chess swag and and gear
whether it's the chess buckles or chess
wallets is still available if you go to
grip6.compogchamps or go.just.com
script6 i've actually got the wallet
right here in front of me it's pretty
awesome
and uh it's anyway
have you seen the wallet levy did you
get did you get a wallet or they only
said it to me
what no of course i mean even if i
didn't of course i would lie on behalf
of the company
i mean capitalism baby no but i do you
know danny it's funny
it actually is super cool and i will i
will like throw some inadvertent shade i
got a new i
ended up getting this new like magnetic
apple apple wallet
and i don't like it because my cards get
stuck in it like legit
and i don't have a way to get them out
the thing about this is like i literally
have it's like the same thinness and i
press this thing and my thing and my in
my cards pop out
so but the problem is now i've split up
my debit cards i've got like my grip six
wallet and then i've got the app
so i'm i'm this is clearly a first world
problem that i'm now venting about
but i do prefer the grip 6 wallet for
that purpose because it pops my cards
out instantly
because i got sticky fingers i use a lot
of lotion on my hands because there's
you know dry skin okay i
i like when the way my brain works when
an interesting subject is being
discussed like my brain is constantly
trying to fire off different jokes
and i i could have gone in so many
different directions
i've given you so much material yeah i
like first
you did you know we we plugged a
different streaming service now we
discredited the physical product of
another company
um what else have we done today we're on
a roll um
hey if apple wants to fix their issues
so that their cars are easy to get on
apple can't do it but
i'm telling you the grip six months
better let's look at this hi chess
people
hello
double what's your move buddy oh it's
nico's move never mind
we're an abomination
all right okay um right uh okay so who's
he listening to
he was he's talking to friends before
the matches i think they're like
doing some oh and he moved this he moved
his camera danny he moved it oh so now
we got to recrop him
that's fine well first of all he moved
his camera because he realized for his
view he was on top of the board
that means we gotta gotta recrop him and
bring his camera back
up thank you wait wait danny someone
someone
sat nico down and told her to stop
playing the bird oh this could be very
bad for tubbo
she doesn't play a fort who is this
person and why didn't she listen to me
our i gave her her first lesson like
before the event started weeks ago and i
was like let's commit now
let's commit now to something else
besides the birds and she
wasn't into it
yeah well did you give her something or
did you just say something besides the
bird
yeah we talked about e4 in fact the
fried liquor in fact she loved it
she loved the fried like we were you
know we were bishop c4 knight g5 attack
seven all day um but i did say at the
time
and and obviously to her credit she
she's you know nico's been playing chess
since she was a kid for those who don't
know
she's played in scholastic tournaments
and she she had a chess club at school
and she i think she got taught the birds
and old habits die hard
right when you know something you don't
want to walk away from it
um that is the worst opening you could
teach a kid like if a coach is teaching
the bird they should be fired
yeah who is that let's find it
um let's also listen into tubbo and just
see what he's screaming about now
yes it's always content here
oh i thought that was a free form for a
second okay
that is the only free square i have
right now i'm not one for giving pieces
away this early on
so i'm gonna just i'm gonna just play it
safe there's no there's no like
shame in retreating god i'm so tired
um right if i lose i'm blaming it on me
being tired just so you're all aware i
am i'm shamelessly blaming it on my
on my on my status i kind of want to
push this pawn forward like that
it's protected by one two three and it's
attacked by one
so if it's taken boom boom
um boom what if it's not boom okay yeah
no they didn't go for that and it's also
protected by one down there
okay right i need i need to be more
aggressive
i always fall behind because i'm never
normally aggressive enough
okay i don't even know if that's true
but levy go ahead
no i i i was it was just i was cracking
up because you know he played d4 and his
logic there was that you know takes
takes takes that's what a lot of people
do they prove they try to prove
themselves right
and they don't think what else can my
opponent do they see one thing if you
try to play a move
five ways it works one way it doesn't it
doesn't work you can't play it you can't
just oh it's a one out of six chance but
i love how he plays that move nico plays
a pawn move on the opposite side of the
board
it's so hard to play nico because she
just plays
she plays quick solid moves takes no
risk
you kill yourself thinking and then she
just overwhelms you and blah blah blah
yeah he played d4 everyone love you
silence she just calmly played h3 and
did so kind of quickly and even though
h3 was
objectively not as good as c4 to avoid
the trade and
this actually might trap the bishop but
but it's a good move
and now she plays b5 she's uh yeah if
nico again someone who sticks with chess
i mean i think that
she's she's done a lot of things um like
just intuitively the fact that she's
playing so quickly um she could be a
very good player for sure
and tubbo by the way chubbo is one of
the few uh streamers in the event that
my kids knew about one and they're like
oh
who's playing in pog champs and i went
through the list and then i was like
tubbo apparently he's big like he
streams like a game called minecraft
ever heard of it
yeah so the interesting thing is like i
mean again i'm thinking like can i joke
about it like obviously i
uh i have first of all younger brother
uh shout out to leo
love that love that kid uh he plays a
lot of minecraft and uh
so shout out leo just got a huge shout
out in front like a hundred thousand
people who can show that to his friends
um he plays a lot of minecraft and
growing up he was like eight nine years
old he was watching all these different
minecrafters and
i've played minecraft once you know i i
just i don't know and i
never really was was too into it but he
uh yeah he knows all these guys he
learned to curse
watching minecraft youtubers probably
watching toppo
i wouldn't even doubt that to be honest
i don't know who he watched
i mean as a new york city kid you don't
need another source to teach you how to
curse
fair for sure um all right well what's
happened here so
ooh oh i was just about to go back in to
see what's happened until
what's happened in front of us is enough
to
focus on i don't know i don't know what
her it's not it's not about criticizing
the blunder i don't know what exactly
her plan was with that like i think that
it's off track with the things she had
been doing right she expanded the pawns
and you would really have loved to play
to move like c4 to keep these pieces on
the edge of the board
definitely would have been the best but
um joe can play 95 and tumble has not
taken the knight yet so he doesn't see
it
maybe yeah he uh he thinks that he's
blundered
like she pushed the pawn b5 to get the
knight out and now she took
but there's he doesn't see it oh my god
did he play bishop v6
totally didn't see it she plays so fast
it freaks people out
yeah 95 was a was a was a free pony
again for those who uh
keeping score at home that that's what
we were freaking out about so wowzers
you know like danny uh i'm gonna make a
personal reference again like
you know lucy my wonderful girlfriend
she'll be playing right and she'll be
playing a 10 10 minute game she's like a
thousand
and her opponent plays every move like
in a second loses all their pieces like
making blunders all and she's sitting
there like
babe i don't know what to do my opponent
is playing so fast i'm like
they're down nine pieces honey like you
know oh no
the feel of it for sure it's and uh okay
e3 is played which
again are not a bad move from the
perspective of
of nico she's trying to open things up
but if temple took here yeah just good
stuff
this is good too yeah knight b3 is a
good move but she's just gonna play
rookie too
right it's it's funny that on the move
where she has no choice she
thinks the most right fascinating
too right that's an interesting
psychology no she doesn't she does it
apparently she does she took me seven oh
my gosh
she's got a fork coming on c6 if rook to
b8 is played
oh my god that's insane tubbo might
actually
like just tunnel vision this and just be
rude knight c6 rook b7 oh my this is
nuts
it's nuts yeah if that's taken so let's
say it's my go i take that i do
i go forward with the exchange um
and i take the queen that gives me like
a direct line
there i could then what i can do is i
can then line that bishop up there and i
can push the bishop forward to them
threaten the castle and it wouldn't be
able to be taken by the king
that's a pretty good idea yes
it they had us in the first half it was
very very good then it kind of cooled
off a little bit but he's got the right
he saw the queen sees the other side or
i could take that pawn there
i could take that pawn i'd lose that
i'd then take that but then the bishop
would escape no i've got a
like there's no easy way for me to save
this oh well i mean i guess i can just
fret
i can always just move the castle i mean
it should have crossed my mind quite
significantly more
then she has just won a pawn and i am
not a fan of that
yeah i could just do that i could just
say that oh look at nico play knight c6
okay now
okay see now the queen's threatened see
that was a mistake i should have seen
that one coming
i wasn't paying enough attention i need
to focus more
all right
oh my god i knew it he was gonna play
queen d5 i was gonna call this
if he plays queen d5 knight e7 wins the
queen doesn't it
it does but if she doesn't see it queen
d5 threatens bishop takes h3 oh my gosh
she's gonna she might take the rook and
then he's gotta see queen takes bishop
because he's looking down this way but
knight e7 that's why you always look for
checks oh it takes the rook
oh oh my god he takes the got away with
that big time
oh i was damn i would have looked so
smart i was gonna call it but i actually
didn't think he was going to play queen
d5 i thought he would play queen d7
but he went the whole distance he he
doesn't and now she's got a
oh man this is a wild game danny knight
c6 was of course best
but i think it's a wild game levy that
might end faster than all of us want as
fans and commentators because the fact
that tubbo has already highlighted
i miss highlight that the light squares
are a problem yes he blundered to get
here with queen d5
and again nico was winning the queen
everybody with this tactic but the fact
that he already saw that
makes me feel like that he he's
he's gonna see bishop takes h3 and
unless nico
okay nice c6 by the way oh bishop h3 she
might play queen a1
yeah she might play queen a1 but she's
gotta oh never mind
okay okay so we're in trade mode
yeah we are in trade mode so what is the
count black has a bishop white has two
pawns but
bishop takes h3 is of course winning and
if you don't play it
yeah this is this is now like and look
how well's nico's
this is now one of those games that like
don't trust the eval bar right because
yes
black is up a piece but if she if he
doesn't go for this plan which
particularly goes really goes really
strong i mean she's got a lot of pawns
for the piece it's not going to be an
easy cleanup
bishop c4
okay rook d1 yeah if tabo doesn't go
back to attacking the king
i don't think that he's going to win
this game unless she blunders but i just
mean
conceptually like yeah he's got it i
agree with you
you alright yeah sorry i might but i had
a long show yesterday with a car
now this one apparently my voices you
know i i'm not a professional streamer
like you i don't i don't you know
your voice muscles are very strong uh
danny
i'm a professional chess content creator
oh sorry
yeah it's the more where it's like
linkedin you know it's like uh you know
you got to add more words to your resume
so it gets to the second line you know
what i mean
replenish the nourishment and the
productivity of the
you gotta yeah i'm so insecure they
invented a chief title just to make me
feel
okay if chess officer what a joke cco
danny danny the trade oh she took
ah she took e4 i know
the knight was pinned for the win
it's still pinned she might see it
because there's not a lot of pieces on
the board i think she's gonna bring her
queen she's gonna play like queen e5 or
something cool right but
95 queen c3 25 probably the most logical
but e4 would win back material on the
spot everybody because the bishop has
pinned
the background checkmate um
oh this is and it's not a hard move to
see actually if you if you go through
the chest thought process of checks
captures attacks
it's the third option she plays oh no
bishop isn't far
all right well elmo's got enough
bouncing heads to keep every adh kid
adhd kid in his audience happy let's go
ahead and check that out
what's the bathroom everything is a
little bit gridlocked and i hate it
look how he hates it but it's totally
winning
i love when someone's winning yeah
everything's a little bit
what video game is this music from
sorry i am just not his demographic i'm
having a seizure
watching all the pieces yeah i want to
get rid of that pig
because that's really annoying
[Music]
oh sonic i'm gonna do that
i don't play any non-dmc
oh did we mute him i don't hear i don't
even know why anyone isn't
and now i mean i just waiting for a next
stream
okay i see an attack i see an attack if
that stays there
if i can line up my queen there i can
check there
and then the king has to move i don't
know because the king moves there that
scarf is my whole thing never mind okay
[Music]
interesting
isn't it
[Music]
he might be the first sub 1000 in
history to spot it
being able to happen for his opponent
yeah
because pretty quickly too i mean we saw
several games yesterday where it was
legit just missed
yeah normally you see it for yourself
you're like oh can i do it and you click
and it's like oh yeah i'm gonna
you don't even you know i have to warn
my subscribers to stop doing that like
just because you can doesn't mean that
you should right
niko threatened the option you have the
option not the obligation to take on
busan
um okay nico by the way look at the
credit the rook lift and the rook slide
to hit g7
and obviously this is still totally
winning for black with best play
doubles just up a free piece but i
actually feel like nico right now levy
is playing with a more coordinated plan
than tobo is right i mean she's
coordinating her pieces for a goal
tebow has uh is struggling to realize
just how winning his position is here
yeah he keeps saying words like
gridlocked but that's you know
you got to stay away from kind of
abstract just terms in general
it's ultimately really it all comes down
to what can you attack and what can they
attack and and
and it's mate i mean it's force made on
the board i think after bishop g2
so bishop g2 when the king moves to g1
you can actually take
h3 which is a fork of brook
and the checkmate um
but again dude he's we're looking at his
he's not even looking for
aggressive moves with the bishop let's
let's go back and look again he's all
about trying to coordinate the rook and
queen
yeah he's actually labeling a move right
now which would throw the game
oh yeah so like that move loses
quick f6
okay wait i think i see a move boom
no because then that will be lost okay
but then rook team won tobo
check king now probably goes
there i don't think the king is going to
go back yep okay
good now i can that was oh my god
like that oh
queen h1 was made 87
22 was also pretty good
then like that kind of like that
you know that yes you can see the metal
for
consistency he's been obsessed with the
battery queen and rook here for many
moves
oh brain firing on all of its available
cylinders at the moment which
indeed is not very many
all right that was pretty funny this kid
gets great he's hilarious
but
hello i think he he and benji are like
by far the youngest participants in the
event like they're like 16 17 like who
is the third youngest player
in the field man it's like like these
guys are
you know for the chess that they've
played
it's uh it is pretty good i'll be honest
when i was 16 17 it wasn't very cool
like at that point
you're in high school you kind of have a
sense of self but like
the younger kids watching like 12 and 13
like it is really
like it's getting more cool to play
chess now it was never cool
back in the day now it's like oh you
play chess oh damn
i'll watch that oh rook c4 played
i think temple's gonna see rook d1 in
fact
he's uh suddenly stopped drumming air
drums by the way the air drums also just
got a lot cooler
what he did um but uh no
he does see it okay it looks like he's
gonna yeah this is
gonna be taking this home now short of
um
yeah no queen f1 like i don't know it's
just a very it's an example of anybody
you hang your queen it's still a game
but bishop d3 now
and or queen d3 and
all right tab on doubles about to play
bishop d3 he has played it
don't even have to take the rook but
okay but suddenly he's in the zone
i think michelle wanted this
i think she wants revenge yeah
yeah i think you want revenge
we could have had a double rematch we
could we almost had benji versus sartosh
and a rematch of this of this group
a double rematch of the brat of their
respective brackets
but you know i don't think that was been
a storyline that
was clear all along at all i mean um
you know okay
see if this ends cleanly and we don't
whenever someone is preparing to get a
second queen levy you know where my
brain goes
stalemate stephen yes like yes
what you got to do at this point you got
to have the skill to set it up so you
got to play like a5 you got to make sure
you have no legal moves but that's good
now you got to go g5 i can't believe
we're coaching this but
yeah get rid of the pawns last legal
move that's first on your agenda play g5
mm-hmm
oh battery i don't i don't i don't think
uh we'll get it we'll get a still me
even any although if king a7 any
if he plays queen b7 oh my god
no just queen b it's made obviously
g5 okay oh no wow wow
okay clean clean
that was clean hey clean stuff yeah he
did no once he
i mean we were we were anticipating a
possible stalemate and by the way that's
not
totally unfair tubbo is actually the one
of the only stalemates we've had in the
event until until
reigns uh king and queen disaster but um
but no once he won that material levy i
mean to be fair to him
if you go back to where rook d1 happened
and to his credit
he had been obsessed with this battery
for like 20 moves
and and and that was his main goal even
though he was missing a lot of other
opportunities
i i i know i'm like uh you know
obviously it's our job to entertain and
provide content but i really do believe
that we were listening to him levy and
let's go back like from right here
he was obsessed with this idea and he
created it
right he legit stopped checkmate along
the way
he went for his battery
and once he won the queen it was like a
grand master took over this was a very
smooth victory from there on out
yes uh the the truth is this uh for
for all of the kind of like joking and
everything like that
he his one thing that he did wrong
in this game was that he didn't win fast
that's it he didn't execute the cleanest
win
from the middle game but he had a plan
he negated all of his opponent's
attempts at creating counter
play and then he won when he got his
chance so
at 800 no seriously
no uh nothing more needs to be said he
had a plan he stuck with it and he
delivered and we are gonna
deliver with more pog champs three
presented by grip6
when we come back
great job
we've got a five minute break we should
resume shortly
that's my
right we have to be more on our a-game
next time because we blundered some
pawns
last game and we didn't look through the
actions like
we didn't look through too much of our
like consequences
we could have messed some stuff up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get down
[Music]
what's going on
[Music]
shoulder back the whole shebang
[Music]
hey i won i know
that was awesome oh one round exactly
[Music]
we do with twitter
[Music]
oh you did it did you did you did you
miss a checkmate this time
i don't know i don't think i did
good good i mean you still won though
what would be really bad is if you
missed the checkmate
and then lost yeah yeah
thank me for my sub forward oh ludwig
oh i missed ludwig's sub let me find it
let me find it
i missed this sub
[Music]
oh god where is it when did you sub
blood glad you haven't announced your
sub it's not there
it's not my alert feed share share the
sub
thank you for the sub ludwig i don't i
don't see the sub though
i don't did he just lie
[Music]
i don't know let me check
okay we haven't gotten to the next game
yet okay okay
oh but look at look at you go check mate
and stuff
mm-hmm yeah yeah you know what that
means yeah i know what that means
that's for sure yeah wait watch this
clip let me watch this clip
i'm curious now
a porn and i am not a fan of that yeah i
could just do that i could just say that
look at niko play knight c6 okay now
okay see now the queen's threatened see
that was a mistake i should have seen
that one coming
i wasn't paying enough yes look at you
porn and i am not a fan of that
i think i counted that pretty well
[Music]
this is only the beginning
and we are back here getting set for the
second game
in the consolation bracket semi-final
remind the community that we are
also raising money for charity remember
that all of the players have picked
charities
and uh you might you might find one
you'd like but we'll remind you of that
here in just a second but we've already
raised
more than 50 000 together because every
dime is matched by chess.com
so if you're watching and we're getting
down to it here
all of these funds go to really
important causes and we we do hope to
reach our goals it would be incredible
so please please consider it if you're
liking what you see in terms of any of
those charities
um go ahead throw in every dime
supported by chess.com
and i might you know you see st jude's
there right it's a
pretty awesome one i know that reigns
charity is super near and dear to him
and his wife's heart
um the work they do in haiti and of
course there's a lot of others too so if
you see
see something you're into supporting
throw in some cash and
uh chess.com will match it all right
here we go
we're on to game two for the semifinals
levy
this could be it this could be the final
final game the semis and uh we will know
our final four participants for the
finals of the
consolation in the champions bracket i
just wanted to say that the chess
community has
an incredible amount of support in it
for like donors to different streamers
but those people those people and a lot
of other people show up for these
charity events day like
yesterday i was playing blitz and
someone in my community said
if you crossed 27.50 today because i was
27 48 which was my highest ever
so i'll donate 27.50 to charity two
people did that
so i crossed it so pancreatic cancer
research yesterday got over five
thousand dollars because
wow no and i know obviously we know that
hikaru has done some incredible streams
recently raising collectively over seven
hundred thousand dollars in the last
couple times he did
uh charity drives right i mean so for
sure and we know that many of you have
been donating
and done some incredible stuff and
yesterday we we really had a blast
uh crushing past our 25 000 goal um
so thank you so much to the community
both in in
part with this event and all the other
streams that uh that they
contribute towards them um e4 played by
devil
does nico know it's her move i guess she
does she's just
kind of getting zen looks like
it's like me when i when i wake up
before i
face my children i really i couldn't
imagine oh no she's just texting someone
oh i'll check my phone
oh no yeah no it's okay that you switch
to the birds after someone else's advice
that's not a big deal
um um i don't i don't know what to do um
uh
this is awkward uh thanks for that
massive 250
donation to charity look at that 250
bucks from destroy computers and that's
not his first dono
during this event levy that guy that guy
i don't know the total off the top of my
head but he has been awesome thank you
so much
destroy computers and by the way i'm
with you let's destroy all computers
like i would literally tear down this
business model if we just want to go
back
to nothing just playing one thing i
really loved about the queen's gambit
just on the topic of trying to like kill
time while seeing figuring out what's
going on with nico
um queen's gambit the one thing i loved
no answers to like chess positions they
would hang out and be like yo that's a
bad move and like no one could
you couldn't pull out a phone and be
like no idiot look like
it was great just talk about chess it's
amazing
it's not like anymore she's playing fast
and uh thank you so much for the
donations continuing to roll in if we
don't shout out every one of you we do
love you
um all right okay we got an open
sicilian happening here look at the uh
the opening repertoires that have
gone nuts and look at the the whatever's
going on at dubbo street
you can't even see him oh it's komodo
hype baby that's what i'm talking about
that's uh i love her
should i say played by nico they're not
the most common move in an open sicilian
but
you know a good one here she's trying to
support the trade on c5
and this one when she close it up
okay nico
she just plays so fast man she plays so
fast
she plays so fast danny she plays so
quickly
it's just like like nico slow down just
a little bit
i hope she doesn't drive this fast
like i mean
but if it works it works
but she can't castle now that's the
problem will she figure out she can
castle queenside
okay doubles just by a little sleepy
earlier but
um let's listen into him the meds seem
to have kicked in he's back
[Music]
oh wait a minute oh no
that's why thank you andrews for 100
donations let's do it
[Music]
oh yeah me too
i want to put pressure i'm getting this
piece out
oh man nico is just yeah whatever that
is living
highway to the danger zone right there
yeah that's fun
this sounds like a highway to the day it
could be a highway to the danger zone
[Music]
let's put this way every dancing emote
on twitch was made for that music
every single one like pepe d i'm talking
cat dance i mean
you name it it was made for that um oh
man i wouldn't be surprised
oh god it's like mate queen reddit we're
headed toward mate on a seven
oh double [ __ ] get your boy in
wisconsin
take the queen and don't look back nico
yeah send us to overtime
whatever oh [ __ ]
and that's why you pay more attention
holy crap i'm an idiot
it's fine we can bring this back from
nico dude no reaction like
zero she took the queen she's she's the
same she get it's the same
it's like that should have happened in
the first game this new trash like i
mean what is going like
like what is i know it's it's the music
it's the awkward you know tom cruise you
know erotica jokes it's tubbo dropping
bombs it's the botes gambit yeah like
like first of all is she okay like i
don't like she
we got tubbo out here jamming out
things flying all over the screen she's
just like she she hella chilling
is that her home in the studio is she
mm-hmm we'll protest gambit
there's awkward checkmates that could
happen here with the rook with the two
rooks on on the open lines with the king
yep this yes their arm
i don't want this match to end too
quickly we got we got some community
donations we're driving and they are
coming in thank you so much so let's
keep the chest going as long as we can
nico and tubbo
let's throw for some donut
yeah seriously more money gets raised
for charity this way it's good you know
it's like
it's like charity boxing matches you
don't want to knock out in round one you
gotta go 12 rounds
as marcelo's wallace would say your ass
goes down in the fifth
but don't do it don't go down to the
fifth go
go bruce willis and change the ending to
that movie
yes i haven't you know speaking of
movies i haven't watched the movie in
forever
i got such a bad attentions man i'm just
on my phone the whole time
what's the last movie you've watched you
have family night like with the movie
um we do actually we watched um we we
usually impact my family movie night
tonight we watched seoul
the disney soul you ever seen that one
the guy
like dead the guy dies but then he comes
he comes back
and anyway disney's soul it was pretty
good
i probably shouldn't even talk about
disney movies anywhere because they'll
sue us
um yeah um
um last the last adult movie not adult
movie the last
the last grown-up time i had
yeah yeah all right last uh the last
i don't even know where we go from here
just uh danny what was it what was it
all right what's funny is regardless of
how wild that got with tubbo
i think if he finds rook d7 winning
winning the queen back once again
um okay he does wow we what is going to
happen in this game i have no idea
well we got some huge donuts i wasn't
paying attention we're over 27 000 maybe
it's been that way for a while
but thank you yeah this is uh no longer
very easy at all taboo's got a bishop
and a pawn but he's got back rank
problems
and rook d2 problems rookie two would be
a very timely move don't go rook d1
huge mistake beginners make just
defending pieces but pinning themselves
don't go rook d1 ooh
i don't she oh if she had seen rook f7
yeah but it's you know you got to
visualize back rank and he's got to
visualize it too but
will he play bishop g4 oh no but
you could also you would also see it if
you just slow down a little bit you
gotta just slow down yes a little bit
it feels sometimes like the first idea
nico sees she just
teaches goes for and you know it's kind
of like that logic mentality
you know he was like i just play you
know i'm not trying to stress too much
i'm not
but you gotta counterbalance that with
also your you know
bloodthirsty desire to just win and
destroy
anything in your path so you gotta hit
the pause button
sometimes yep well i mean
not in exactly the same context here but
i mean you and i both
coach professionally and you do have
students that that are like that even
even of the most talented nature where
you start to realize
or you start to get them to see like hey
just because you
see a move and you see these ideas so
fast
doesn't mean you have to play them so
fast right like and you really start to
try to give them techniques to develop
discipline by the way b5 was played
instantly by nico and a great move by
nico
she played it instantly there you go
bishop b3c
yeah just that if she sees c4 now she
might play rook d1 okay she sees her
there you go
sorry guys what are we gonna add no she
just traps it and uh
i i was gonna say this ultimately chess
is uh
is a lens into how you behave in kind of
all elements of your life so like i
taught
a kid from from second grade up to sixth
and
for five straight years he had the same
problem in chess
as he had in school his parents were
like we can't get him to slow down he
comes back with a 90 on the math exam
because he added three plus five in a
calculation made it nine
and he he knows all the concepts he
knows how to do it he just
first one done lost 10 points because of
silly mistakes so
it's everywhere man it's not just just
you too fast everywhere it is psychology
in a lot of ways and and uh and it
doesn't mean people don't you know
i mean we've i've had students that were
you know maybe
a lot more timid at certain times and
then they like grow and and all of a
sudden they get confidence for whatever
reason you know and now
now they're doing things at a super high
level with the knowledge that was always
in there but it's just being executed so
so many things can change but
chess really is psychology and by the
way nico if we just go back to this
position
he played instantly but this this a6 b5
c4 like no hesitation bring the rooks
to the second rank she's crushing it now
yes the only chance oh the rook
oh did she see that oh yeah she's going
over to
kids i i think it's happening let's hope
joshua chamberlain doesn't live on that
one
and that we don't get a stalemate or
anything but if we go to overtime
we're gonna have a lot more fun today
oh totally i mean nico this is her this
will be her second armageddon
uh she won the first against rubius
right or
was that who she won the uh against she
played ruby as she won the first he won
the second they went to
armageddon i think okay i think that's
how it went there was one chance if you
if you back up
i just want to show this to people uh
for for for taboo before he gave the
check on a8 he could have walked his
king and maybe checkmated
yep right that it's the one way you're
going to win here the
your rook is doing something called
cutting off the king yeah
or even right here if you keep the king
trapped and bring the king up there was
this outside idea for sure
i think tobo's already in i gotta get
back to some air drums
it's getting it's getting close danny i
mean there's a way you can stalemate
here but uh she's going to bring the
uh oh when i first looked at it i
thought it was her move and i thought
she might be about to play king g6
ah that is a stalemate you are right
okay it's over she found it king h5
h1 we're going overtime
dude this is great bog champs is so
great
eco still hasn't smiled in a long time
it's kind of there
it's it's kind of sit there a smile
nope okay oh thumbs up all right
i'm smiling
every time people are like man what do
you do for a living and i say
i commentate on chess
we'll be right back
[Music]
yeah i know i should have taken that
pawn i know
i know i should have done that instead
of castled
oh god i'm just such an idiot
i guess my brain dude what the heck
ludwig is dm me you got this tower oh
god okay
don't be too eager to attack um make
sure
homes good before you go to wars okay
okay okay thank you lord thank you
got you i got you i got you tuba i got
you
tie breaker is a very simple single game
of chess five-minute
five-minute chess no increment whoever
wins wins nico has
white okay
oh wow chess.com knows how to give the
correct people the correct pieces now
that's cool because
feels like that's a new thing they've
learned didn't think they had that
technology in the past
like oftentimes they get the wrong
colors so
good that the top seed got the right one
this time
rayne wilson my name is pronounced
ludwig not ludwig although correctly
it is pronounced ludwig but i'm just not
german i'm a [ __ ] white american
who eats mcdonald's on saturdays
ah anyway what's up
hess hess is dead to me i'm a celtics
fan he sent me this this morning
i had two celtics tickets in my car and
someone broke in and left three more
smfh
you all stay safe like bro why you gotta
do me like that
i lost yesterday oh wait wait wait
chess.com it's actually the perfect time
to show you this clip
hold up let's see if i can find it in
time clutch gaming performances
live on air clock
winding down here will he be able to
find it surely
great games everyone are you done yeah i
gotta i gotta do the calls
okay wait do we have to do it right now
uh i don't think you have
to do it but um i'm gonna do it later
i'm gonna run it now and then there's
also the um the pog champs match
oh good look at that good luck good luck
good luck don't get forked right yeah
uh so i got eliminated yesterday oh
great games everyone are you done yeah i
got a
same shirt this happened literally two
hours ago
two [ __ ] hours ago they says to me
good luck
like i didn't get my ass handed to me by
in game three
i had like 200 000 people watching it
across all the streams like
i thought they wouldn't know i i tweeted
i has
i did not tweet i has after crushing
sardosh decisively in a 3-0 victory
stop saying same shirt as if i should
change the shirt
from two out i wore it two hours ago
it's i've been live
i it's not it's the same day you don't
change shirts dated
didn't it's not weird to wear the same
shirt in the same day
yeah the hair is the same that's always
the same though
even when you get it cut it's the same
hey [ __ ] you fuckchest.com
let's go tubbo
make make sure you mess up the colors
again
oh sorry we're live okay we're back um
what we've got here is a tie break
coming up here we've got
uh sudden death with 5.0 not armageddon
anymore levy so you said nico has
already won armageddon match but this is
not armageddon it is just simply 5-0 and
we will switch colors
until we have a winner um and
yes yes that that i guess is the main
difference in armageddon match one side
has more time and the other side has
draw odds
uh but uh yeah i'm just used to calling
it armageddon sudden death
sudden death or playoff or whatever
um but it is it is um
it is going to be sudden death meaning
the moment you lose you're out but if
it's a draw the games will continue
and uh i i hope we go forever by the way
shout out to the 50
donut we had right there before we came
back we saw you thank you so much so
okay nico versus tubo it's overtime we
saw that lud was actually texting tubbo
advice
rooting on his man um
blitz i gotta give the nod to nico
because she
freaking fast yeah i was gonna say
there's no bonus time
and i mean she's gonna go real quick
she's got practice moving pieces in one
second
double's gotta always gotta think he's
gotta not get nervous
and i have no idea who gets what color
we're going to find out right now
nico's got white nico's got white okay
and uh and we're off to see the wizard
so wow look at her mixing it
up now she's all over the map forget the
birds
yeah she gonna play b3 or g3 what's she
gonna do
d3 okay okay
let's play guess the move with nico uh
you got to say it now because she's
probably already pretty g3
g3 i'll say e3 ether oh that's a good
one i should have said that
so now okay one nothing danny okay next
move
is gonna be oh god
h g three h three oh um there we go
all right one one one one all right i
think i think we know the next one danny
i think we know bishop g2
so be too soon
okay she's already pre-moved bishop
bishop no
don't you don't dude if you get if
whoever wins this game gets the nikko
that takes some real skill
oh if he takes i don't know what she's
going to take back with oh my god i'm
trying to get into nico's head um
he takes if e takes she's gonna say with
the e pawn so i guess you gotta take the
other one right
yeah i'll i'll i'll i'll take g takes if
she sticks
if you take so it's one one right now
because neither of us guessed f4
tubbo was shook dude tubbo was shook he
is
i mean he's too long what okay bishop gt
oh b3
okay nope whoa
um knight f3 nope
i didn't realize that we were still uh
though we were still this is too fast
pace for me uh pawn takes pawn she's
gonna play oh my god i would
dude i'm so scared i gotta work queen up
one no
fast and by the way jokes aside she's up
a minute on the clock this is why i
picked her to win this
tiebreaker now she plays knight now of
course he should just shred it open pawn
takes pawn
she'll respond to a pawn takes pawn if
that happens yeah well knight d4
would be basically winning for black i
saw someone chat saying explain why
black is winning here
white has moved way too many pawns and
not developed pieces
and this is a devastating pin if oh okay
he plays bishop before nineteen
was much better she's gonna play bishop
e2
don't take please don't take don't just
i think she sees it
rook b1 wow that's you know so she's
protecting the bishop
um and she's playing fast
right i mean
she's definitely a natural blitz player
i will
someone said that wow okay uh i don't
know what she's gonna do she's gonna
play uh h3
when in doubt move upon oh i was gonna
say that but then i was like no way move
that is a good move yeah the biggest
user
good i was gonna say tuple's been very
trade averse
yeah and he might not take and he might
hang his bishop
she's gonna take the bishop hopefully
she might take the night nope
she took the knight double take
you should we choose the move niko unpin
your knight
oh god okay it's good good good he's got
oh now if he takes
he hangs his queen okay he's gonna say
chances tobo plays he takes f4
he can't i can't watch they play it they
okay no knight d4
okay bishop takes good she can't castle
though she can't count
this is a this is a real problem and
you're
going to be the best bishop of all
timelines
you know if double plays pawn c five
pawn b6 he gets the legendary connect
five
that's pretty like that that's pretty
decisive
h3 was a good move by nico i think that
again she's slowed down a little bit
with the time on the clock and so if she
can get out of the bind she's in somehow
very tricky this is a horn sure but
still think that remember there's no
increment coming no help coming so tubo
has got to do something before it's too
late
okay she's gonna take back yeah he's got
two minutes to break through a
completely locked structure this is not
easy
at all
yeah i mean the ways to do it you've got
to find something with
okay g5 is one crazy idea but even even
c6 and d5
gotta open up lines fast she's thinking
about what you're thinking about like
this is a snap take moment kind of just
don't even
i think she's just trying to make this
dramatic for us
it's crazy because the best move here
for black is probably some wild thing
like d5 or b5 or c6 and d5 or b5 just
that's
not bad but that's not gonna open the
position
yeah it's not a bad move but again
you're down a whole minute on the clock
eco should just shuffle
oh that opens up this idea
yes this is getting
well i would just trade the queen and
now it's a very low chance that you get
checkmated it's a high chance you might
blunder a rook
but
this is objectively even even if this
were just two strong players
playing this is very close to a draw
with obstacle bishops
yeah she's gotta just not
i'm gonna say like she just has to not
play e5 that's all yeah just don't play
e5 like
don't don't keep one
yep it's the art of doing nothing in
chess
the art of doing nothing but now she has
a lot of play she's going to get rook a1
maybe e5 and maybe bishop takes rook
yeah okay now just run your king to
safety over
here i think she's put herself in a
really good spot because she played fast
her her greatest skill really in terms
of the disparity between her and her
opponents has been how quickly she's
done things and it's really going to pay
off in blitz
will she remember son oh this is so
wow a5 changes though oh she's played e5
it's the
oh danny i'm going crazy
but rook takes wasn't played but now
tubbo's speeding up
yeah he's also speeding up that's the
thing he's realized that he don't want
to lose on time he's only 20 seconds
away
now she might freeze up from nerves
look at this king oh my god these ships
this is crazy danny
no back up uh oh she might get made it
she might get made it in the middle of
the board something completely insane
yeah like one of those accidental
checkmates
put your king on the wrong square come
on give her give a check give a check or
get that other rook in the game tubbo
that now's not the time to tank buddy
that's a great move
that's a great move if he sees rookie
three especially to follow it
don't go rookie one just don't think
here comes d3 he plays it without having
to be asked this is moving too quickly
oh g-flat what a save don't take it
oh that's a good move
that too putting on the uh check he's
still
he's still blabbering away over there
he's got to not hang his rook sometimes
you have this blind spot king attacks
rook and then king takes rook and you
just forget
don't
don't forget about that 15 seconds the
difference on time oh it might happen
yeah he might forget and push his spot
losing himself into the
[Music]
dancing
this is insane danny oh geez on the
bishop
oh he finds it it finds oh but now now
now the pass pawn now dude this could
backfire the b-pawn
okay what a move although if she sees b8
as an x-ray tactic that would just be
bananas i think she might just push
because like what else do you do okay
she goes up
now he oh that's a great move and that
would be six
oh my gosh great technique with no time
only 40 seconds
this is insane 50 uh i mean five seconds
is the difference
takes takes v7 first now he can take b5
and there's no back rank danny the the
most important thing
there's no background checkmate but
there is enough material on the board
that either player could still flag
the fact that he's under 30 seconds this
is gonna
oh man forget the eval bar it's all that
matters is the time off the board
neither player is gonna mate in this
amount of time left levy this is gonna i
think she's gonna win on the clock i'm
sorry but that's what's gonna happen
yeah if you're playing with black here
in this and and and you're in a game
it's not about mates about taking all
the pieces off the board without rook
training
yeah yes
absolutely
oh he's got the pawn that's good yeah
but now get the
not enough time and look at her she's
practically pre-moving
yeah the problem is that if are they
going to repeat oh they're going to i
thought we were about to see a repeat
we might see it how crazy would that be
five seconds
she's pre-moving moving
nico removing her way to the
championship match
in the consolation bracket this is crazy
that's how you get it done boys right
there you pretty move your way all the
way to victory wow and she smiled
someone clip it fast enough
no 90 seconds
that's heartbreaking oh man
that's heartbreaking but that's chess
baby that's
winner take all wow
heartbreaking for tubbo we have a
a battle of i mean opposites in terms of
style and approach in many ways between
michelle carrey
and uh and uh nico in the final i don't
even know how to make sense of what we
just saw
but i do know we're going to talk to the
players in just a few moments so don't
go anywhere
interviews with nico
and tubo pogchamps3 presented by grip6
in just a moment
interview i would love to listen to
their interview
and now we know it's an all girls final
oh girls final
let me invite you to your board was it
this
yeah it's this game why is it
why is it saying one zero on chess.com
oh one zero okay i thought it said zero
one okay i can't read
my country i was like how did black win
when black lost on time
i think we're on chess.com are we
are we i heard us on the stream hello
everybody
this is bakchio's finalists misha curry
we've been watching consolation
the consolation it's still a final
michelle you made it and now we know
your opponent we've been watching the
match between toppo and nico
um i'm very biased that i've been
rooting for an august final because i've
been working
both with nico and michelle and now the
two of you will play against each other
michelle your first thoughts about what
has just happened in the tiebreaker
and it was so awesome niko played so
fast it was really exciting to watch and
i'm really
really excited and honored to play her
tomorrow it's gonna be awesome
and you can share with the rest of the
viewers on chess.com as well that
you have actually played a mini match
against nico
a few weeks ago i did i did
at the sort of the beginning of this
journey and
um she's very good it is it was very
intense
it was a training much set up by the
botus sister shout out to alexandre
nandra for the initiative because they
organized couple of training matches for
you guys for the punctures participants
and
i thought that was a very very useful
training additional training for you to
be in a competitive
tournament situation not just play
against viewers or random
people but also to to have the same form
at the same time control in a match
situation so
that was one one i believe the training
match
and there the tie breaker was just a
puzzle solving session puzzle rush
which destroyed me in the puzzle right
you weren't
familiar with that for a tie breaker and
and you were very nervous
that training match you had against nico
you were really nervous in both games
you have gone
you have come so far since you have
improved so much more in terms of how
you deal with
pressure and how how to
turn that nervousness into being excited
about oh this is a challenge this is
great i'm gonna i'm gonna put out my put
myself out there i'm gonna
try my best i'm gonna do my best and we
will see what happens
because you've been doing really well
since michelle this
yesterday's matches double win for
michelle
double win
i don't know how long oh that we have 50
seconds to the interview i was gonna
invite you to
an analysis board or maybe the one we
had i could just
change um let me set up their game and
we can quickly open it to for ourselves
basically what nico missed if you see
the
position michelle the analysis what we
had earlier if you go back to that
same one yeah these dot com slash live
yeah do you still have can you reinvite
me oh sure yeah
sorry no worries no worries i forgot
that it might it might not be
there
and we are back here with our final
interview of the day we've got
tubbo and nico nico it took it took
three games but you finally smiled at
the end of the last game there
take us through take us through your
thought process and how were you nervous
were you just
stone cold killer focused what was going
on in your head
uh all all i've heard up until this
match i was that tower was
temple was really good and i was like oh
my god like he's gonna beat me like i
already came in here with the mentality
to get
like stomped on but i was like wait wait
i actually think
i possibly might have a chance so you
know i've regardless i stayed hopeful
but nonetheless like
i was very sweaty because he was playing
he was like predicting my moves pretty
well and i was like oh my god like i
can't believe he's like
predicting every one of my moves but um
but yeah it was definitely like a
a challenge i would say so
i it was it was pretty it was pretty
good i was also i i'm also dealing with
a huge headache right now but
i've made it through well then wait way
to go way to push through it
i know this didn't go no no no i i i
think i need to drink some water after
this i think i'm just dehydrated
how are you feeling right now i know it
didn't go how you wanted but it was as
close as it could possibly
get it was a great time it was very very
close
oh man the time out at the end i was
trying to check as many times as i could
as fast as i could
i didn't know it was just not enough
time i guards down at the clock and saw
there was three seconds left and i was
like uh-oh
i would do you play blitz a lot like
five minutes because i know for this
it's all mostly rapid and practice
generally we say rap do you play like
three or five at all
i played one minute quite a lot just on
my phone in bed
that's what i have same yeah and danny
too
i think i think that's actually that's
pretty much too um
but uh yeah well tobo you've now played
in you
you've had a lot of chess right you
played block champs you played in pog
champs here what has been your
experience overall
how do you feel about your chest in
terms of where you were to where you've
come and
did you have a good time it's got it's
got a lot more
i've got i feel like i've got a lot
better but i'm not sure because when i
started i was a little bit confused
about all the strategies and all the
weird names
and i think i've kind of got the weird
names in the bag now or the ones that i
know of anyway
yeah i think uh
what is the percent balance when you're
playing in these events that you have to
entertain a
massive community of supporters and also
like focus because it feels
like no i'd say it's like 60 40.
yeah it's i was gonna say it feels like
a lot i feel like if you get to play off
stream and just grind a little bit i
think i think your focus is there
because you definitely
you know you you catch on you plan
things out well but
you do have a pretty big responsibility
there as well um
danny i was gonna ask nico uh nico i
feel like danny and i talked about this
the final of the consolation with you
and michelle
it's like polar opposite styles right so
you are fast and when the game opens up
you find like the tactics that become
available
michelle is very slow and methodical so
how have you scouted her out as an
opponent at all
and like what do you think uh what do
you think that final is gonna be like
for you i actually
have played against michelle and and
this is very true like she's very um
methodical i i
i don't know how it's going to play out
i mean and the the tactics i use with
with chubbo
were like i tried because i feel like i
don't know
maybe if this is not true or maybe it is
but i feel like he already knew what my
opening was
so i was trying to see if i could throw
him off and see like what is she doing
or like is
so that that's kind of like the tactic
that i try to use because it's like
i don't i haven't had time to like learn
other openings because i was moving and
then the storm and everything so i was
trying to like
just juke my opponents if i could
but uh but yeah i like going fast so
not nothing's gonna change there when i
go up against michelle
well it obviously makes you super
dangerous if we get to a tie break as we
know it and
nico you you know we said in the
beginning you were you were streaming
chess before chess was cool
long ago before the first pog champs now
that you're moving into the final of the
consolation
is it is it cool for you that given that
chess was one of the first things you
were you were streaming um
before it was as popular as it's been as
it's been now and
um what would it mean to you to win
tomorrow
um it would be actually a lot i feel
like when i first started playing chess
there was like this
um elitist kind of vibe over the chess
community like
you know you had to be like fide master
grand master super saiyan power
3000 elo but now like
um i feel it's a lot more chill and i
feel like
it could show that other content
creators could also uh
play chess and have fun and get better
and be good
uh including myself so um i think that
that is kind of what i'm hoping to
approve tomorrow by winning
cool all set um it was very funny
i'm gonna miss the eardrums bro i'm not
gonna lie i'm gonna miss the eardrums a
lot
oh man without attraction the eardrums
no everything was man uh
all the music i mean it's just cool i
think it's cool to see so many different
people from so many different categories
with so it's where are the eardrums
oh uh you know one last time tubbo
you just do that when you're like when
you're like in the in the in the game
and like in the
good song
well tubby you are a lot of fun to watch
seriously and uh we
we it's been awesome having you we hope
to maybe see you again in future
yes kind of kind of shows 100 percent i
agree with levy i think
i think you you entertain well and we
definitely get this vibe that if there
was a little bit of a calmer
kind of chill or chest focus stream it's
really hard to say what your
what your ceiling might be because you
know you do a lot of things really well
and it's been awesome to watch
oh thank you man i will enjoy the rest
of your weekend nico
you got it you now have a date tomorrow
on sunday we know what you're doing with
your weekend right you got pog champs
and uh we'll see you at 12 pacific
tomorrow for your battle versus michelle
thank you and that gg tubo it was really
good playing with you
it was very fun thank you for the games
thanks guys guys
ggs right right
well there you have it the bracket is
filled levy
michelle and nico in the final
this is uh this is awesome man i don't
know if you know the uh the story of
michelle in this event
uh i think you do the full story right
like it's uh yeah yeah
you just i got an email one day from the
host of challenge accepted and we were
talking chess
we like spoke on the phone and then she
was like what would be a good final goal
and i was like we got this little thing
coming up called pogchamp she's like
what's that i was like
let me tell you about pogchamps michelle
and this was
literally the dream because we knew that
the stack feel of the
championship bracket would be too
difficult but this is it danny this
might be the culmination of our whole
project
seriously and and we know that michelle
is going to put together an amazing
whatever it is what do we call what she
does it's challenge accepted it's a
documentary style
kind of breakdown of of her experiences
she commits to specific
tasks and goals and tries to master them
so if you don't know her content you
should definitely just google
michelle carey check out her youtube
channel it's really cool stuff
and yeah i think whether she wins or
loses tomorrow she made it
to the finals so i feel like it almost
it almost doesn't matter it's almost a
win for her
channel and content as far as the story
of committing to something like a pog
champs event and trying to win it
and maybe she'll go all the way by the
way
we will also have the championship match
right after that of course and i'm also
being updated now
so you know that it will actually be 1
20 pacific so it does not start at noon
tomorrow the consolation
match between nico and michelle starts
at 1 20
pacific time and then the championship
will take place at 2
40 p.m pacific time obviously give or
take
a few minutes here and there as we do on
these things when you know you get
overtime or you get other stuff so
levy this has been a lot of fun we got
to do this more often this whole thing
you know this this relationship it
there's something here i agree
uh and and we showed up matching i
didn't know you were going to wear that
and uh is that wearing bright salmon is
that a salmon color that's
what is i don't think you're supposed to
pronounce the l in that word but
i i just really like pink hoodies so i
always wore blue and black
my whole life and gray uh and then um
now recently i was like you know what
i'm bored so i upgraded to maroon i got
purple i got pink
i wear you know they the thing about
being a streamer danny we'll say it's a
bubble gum
color everybody sees your sh your
clothes every day when you stream so
like i got to bring bright colors to the
table because i'm going to run out of it
yeah so
well um anyway it's been awesome i will
be back tomorrow with icaro for the fans
that are still here with us make sure
you tune in it will be the championship
battles for both the consolation
and the championship bracket
respectively so
shout out again to everyone who's been
here thank you so much for the community
i'm hoping that we'll reach our
our goals tomorrow and and continue to
do all the things we can to make sure
these charities
get the support they deserve the crew
here
international master levy rosman high
five that's me
oh oh sorry i i was looking at my camera
because you know we got to be my bad
i didn't mean to wait i got you i got
you all right ready yeah
what we did uh oh okay oh one more time
all
right
ready go bam all right
i felt that danny i felt that thanks for
being here everyone
and uh we will see you tomorrow for more
pogchamps 3 presented by grip6
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
three two one here we go
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
get out check it out
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
you